this is Jaco podcasts number 105 with
echo Charles and me jogger willing good
evening echo good evening specialist
Vieira was witness to scenes of horror
the enemy was all over at least a couple
hundred of them walking around for three
or four minutes it seemed like three or
four hours they were shooting and
machine-gunning are wounded and laughing
and giggling I knew they'd kill me if
they saw I was alive when they got near
I played dead I kept my eyes open and
stared at a small tree
I knew that dead men had their eyes open
Vieira continues then one of the North
Vietnamese came up looked at me then
kicked me and I flopped over I guess he
thought I was dead
there was blood running out of my mouth
my arm my legs he took my watch in my 45
caliber pistol and walked on I watched
them strip off all our weapons they left
then they left back where they came from
I remember the artillery the bombs the
napalm everywhere real close around me
it shook the ground underneath me but it
was coming in on the north vietnamese
soldiers too
all this and more much more took place
between 650 a.m. and 7:40 a.m. on
November 15th 1965 the Agony's of
Charlie Company occurred over a hundred
and forty yards of the line but men were
fighting and dying on three sides of our
thinly held American perimeter in the
center I held the lives of all of these
men in my hands the badly wounded
Captain Bob Edwards was on the radio now
asking for reinforcements the only
reserve I had was a reconnaissance
platoon 22 men
was the attack on Charlie Company the
main enemy threat Delta Company and the
combined mortar position were also under
attack now reluctantly I told captain
Edwards that his company would have to
fight on alone for the time being the
din of the battle was unbelievable
rifles and machine guns and mortars and
grenades rattled banged and boomed two
batteries of 105 millimeter howitzers 12
big guns located on another landing zone
five miles distant were firing non-stop
their shells exploding no more than 50
yards outside the ring of shallow
foxholes beside me in the battalion
command posts the air force forward
controller lieutenant Charlie W Hastings
26 from La Mesa New Mexico radioed a
special codeword Broken Arrow meaning
American unit in danger of being overrun
and within a short period of time every
available fighter bomber in South
Vietnam was stacked overhead at a
thousand foot intervals from 7,000 feet
to 35,000 feet waiting it's turn to
deliver bombs and napalm to the
battlefield among my sergeants there
were three war men men who parachuted
into Normandy on d-day and had survived
the war in Korea and those old veterans
were shocked by the savagery and hellish
noise of this battle
choking clouds of smoke and dust
obscured the killing ground we were dry
mouth and our bowels churned with fear
and still the enemy came on in waves
and that right there is from the opening
chapter of the book We Were Soldiers
Once and young by General Hal Moore and
joe galloway and the book which was
turned into a movie which I saw when it
came out in 2002 Mel Gibson it's a good
movie for sure but it's also a Hollywood
movie and Hollywood movies they're
forced to fit into two hours and they
got to follow some kind of a plot and
they can't dig into the details and I
can't really give you a comprehensive
understanding of the events and I
purposely did not watch this movie again
while preparing for this podcaster
because I didn't want it in there and I
won it in my brain the movies
interpretation of the characters in it
and the way that they were portrayed and
the book is so good and it's so packed
with detail and drama and action and an
utterly incomprehensible heroism
everyone should read this book everyone
it starts off it explains the way the
battle unfolded and it talks how it went
tactically operationally and
strategically goes through all those
levels of warfare and you can see in the
book how strategy unfolds at the
tactical level and how tactical
situations impact strategy is well you
can see it on both sides and there's
also which is interesting there's
significant commentary from the
Vietnamese enemy leadership that they
went back and interviewed after the war
was over which just makes it an
incredible book like I said everyone
should read it so it tells the story of
operations in the I drank Valley in 1965
from November 14th until November 18th
so five days
but the fighting as was noted in that
opening chapter is absolutely brutal
leadership is tested over and over and
over again and this battle took place
with battalions and companies from the
seventh Cavalry Regiment and if you
remember the books we covered on General
George Custer
he was a officer that led 7th cavalry
troops in the battle Little Bighorn
where he was surrounded and he was
killed along with 267 of his soldiers
all of them dead by the Native American
warriors on the suicide from the Lakota
and the Dakota and the Northern Cheyenne
and Arapaho tribes and cavalry in those
days meant horseback that's what I meant
that's what mounted cavalry that's what
it was and in 1965 they adopted cavalry
to a new kind of steed a new form of
transport and this was the helicopter
and in 1965 they converted the 11th Air
Assault test division to the 1st Cavalry
Division and the 1st and 2nd battalions
of the 1st Cavalry Division soon took on
the historical name of general Custer's
unit and and by the way general cost the
7th calves even though that's kind of
the most famous along with this I guess
along with the I drank valley but their
day the the 7th calves in world war ii
and korea all kinds of incredible
service there and and a lot of that is
covered in the book but again we'll have
to move through this a little bit more
quickly otherwise go read the book which
I highly recommend
but let's get into it starting about
where lieutenant colonel Hal Moore takes
over the 1st battalion 7th Cavalry going
back to the book on Monday June 29th as
scheduled I took command of my battalion
I was 42 years old a West Point graduate
of the class of 1945 with 19 years
commissioned service including 14 month
tour in Korea the combat tour in Korea
in a brief talk to the Troops afterward
I told them that this was a good
battalion but it would get better I will
do my best I said and I expect the same
from each of you before taking command I
had a long talk with the most important
man in any battalion the sergeant major
basil L Plumlee 44 years old and six and
a 6 foot 2 inch bear of a man hailed
from West Virginia the men sometimes
called him old iron jaw but never in his
hearing
plumlee was a too warm man and War
Master parachute wings with his five
combat jump stars he was what the young
airborne types called a four jump
bastard
Plumlee had survived all four combat
jumps of the 82nd Airborne Division in
World War two Sicily and Salerno in 1943
then and then in 1944 d-day at Normandy
and Market Garden in the Netherlands for
that matter
he also made one combat parachute jump
in the Korean War with the 187th
Airborne Infantry Regiment he ended
World War two a buck sergeant and was
promoted to sergeant major in 1961 so
let's think about that for a minute
let's think about that I mean we've
talked we've definitely talked about
Normandy we definitely talked about
Market Garden he jumped into both those
and jumped into Sicily and Salerno and
jumped into combat in the Korean War
unbelievable
going back to the book the sergeant
major was a no-bullshit guy who believed
as I did in tough training tough
discipline and tough physical
conditioning to this day there are
veterans of the battalion who are
convinced that God may look like
sergeant major basil Plumlee but he
isn't nearly as tough as the sergeant
major on sin's small or large
privately I thanked my lucky stars that
I had inherited such a treasure I told
sergeant major Plumlee that he had
unrestricted access to me at any time on
any subject he wish to raise after the
ceremony the company commanders and the
battalion staff got a look at their new
boss and a word on my standards they
were fairly simple only first-place
trophies will be displayed accepted or
presented in this battalion second place
in our line of work is defeat of the
unit on the battlefield and death for
the individual in combat no fat troops
or officers decision making will be
decentralized push the power down it
pays off in wartime loyalty flows down
as well I check up on everything I am
available day or night to talk with any
officer of this battalion finally the
sergeant major works for only for me and
takes orders only from me he is my
right-hand man
so he's set in the stage pretty
interesting in the only first place
trophies 2nd place no not happening here
back to the book the officers of my new
battalion were the usual great army mix
of men who had come from their jobs come
to their jobs from West Point
ROTC Officer Candidate School and
military schools like the Citadel most
of the young second lieutenants had come
through OCS and college ROTC programs
there were three rifle companies in the
battalion alpha Bravo and Charlie
companies each at full strength supposed
to have six officers in 164 enlisted men
they were my manoeuvre elements each
rifle company had three rifle platoons
plus one platoon of
three 81-millimeter mortar squads for
fire support each rifle platoon in turn
had three rifle squads plus a weapon
squad of two m60 machine guns for fire
support so there's there's the breakdown
right there then they also had a another
combat support company Delta Company
which had a recon platoon a mortar
platoon and an anti-tank platoon and
they converted the unneeded anti-tank
platoons in a machine gun platoon for
for duty in Vietnam because there was no
enemy tanks going up against so that's
that's what the battalion was looking
like going back to the book during the
during those first fourteen months and
now he's gonna talk about their work up
a little bit how they got ready for
combat back to the book during those
fourteen months before we sailed for
Vietnam we spent most of the time in the
field practicing assault landings from
helicopters and the incredibly complex
coordination of artillery tactical air
support and aerial rocket artillery with
the all-important flow of helicopters
into and out of the battle zone
commanders had to learn to see terrain
differently to add a constant scan for
landing zones which are called L Z's and
pickup zones
P Z's to all the other features they had
to keep in mind we practice rapid
loading and unloading of men and
materiel to reduce the helicopters
window of vulnerability total
flexibility was the watchword and
planning and attitude there was one bit
of sobering reality that I insisted be
introduced at every level in this
training we would declare a platoon
commander dead and Tate let his sergeant
take over and carry out the mission or
declare a sergeant dead and have one of
his PFC s take over running the squad we
were training for war and leaders are
killed in battle I wanted every man
trained for and capable of taking over
the job of the man above him so they're
working a whole new gig here they never
no one had really done this before
riding everyone's going into combat on
helicopters and obviously helicopters
give you great amount of maneuverability
you can be up vertically and takeoff and
travel a great distance and set down
anywhere or not anywhere just about
anywhere you can set down in a lot of
places I should say because you can't
set down anywhere especially in the
jungle we got trees and all kinds of
obstacles
and then you've got enemy on top of that
and helicopters are pretty vulnerable
flying machines and so this idea what
what they were practicing was this
massive movement move all the troops
into the combat zone very quickly and
the enemy doesn't expect you then you
can just show up there so it's that's
what they're practicing over and over
again and clearly you know a Korean War
veteran like Hal Moore was he knows that
leaders can get killed in combat and so
he's sometimes killing the leaders in
training and that's a tradition we still
had we do that all the time when I was
running training the SEAL Teams the
minute the leaders started to get a grip
on things it was like okay you're dead
next man's gonna step up and sometimes
that would just wreck a platoon or a
task unit well the leader dies if
they're a good leader and they're not
and no one is used to stepping up it'd
be problematic but sometimes it would
actually be beneficial you get some guy
that's a micromanager kill him and then
watch everything run smoothly and you
come back and you go dude you better
back off a little bit because this guy's
run in a better show then you are and
it's really clear so sometimes we teach
guys lessons that way huh back to the
book unfortunately my battalion and
every other in the division now began to
suffer the consequences of President
Johnson's refusal to declare a state of
emergency and extend the active duty
tours of draftees and reserve officers
the order came down any soldier who had
less of less who had 60 days or less
left to serve on his enlistment as of
the date of deployment August 16th must
be left behind we were sick at heart we
were being shipped off to war sadly
under-strength
and crippled by the loss of almost a
hundred troopers in my battalion alone
the very men who would be the most
useful in combat those who had trained
the longest and the new techniques of
helicopter warfare were by this order
taken away from us it made no sense then
it makes no sense now so again I talked
about the strategic kind of implications
that these guys felt and this is one of
them and obviously I'm jumping through
the book they talks more about the
workup and what they did to prepare but
now he's getting this point where
President Johnson doesn't declare a
state of emergency and keep these guys
in and so
you know that's a political decision
obviously but what aware is an impact
ensure it impacts the guys on the front
line that's where it impacts now like I
said this book is written not only by
not only by Lieutenant General Howe more
is how are you retired in this book I'll
refer to him as lieutenant colonel or
sometimes I guess I'm just disrespectful
and call him how more I don't mean it
disrespectfully but anyways how Moore
wrote the book but he also wrote the
book along with another guy named Joe
Galloway and you know you know what a
ghostwriter is yeah yeah ghostwriter
well this is so go try to write a
person's book but no one's supposed to
know it and then there's people that
write the book but they get credit for
it and you might think that's a
situation here looking at the title
because you've got Lieutenant General
Harold Moore retired and Joseph L
Galloway like you know it doesn't say
any service thing well in this
particular case that could give you an
absolutely wrong impression because Joe
Galloway was a reporter a combat
reporter who was obviously he was very
courageous and and basically got after
it for lack of a better word so i'll
going where they introduced him a little
bit back to the book UPI reporter joe
galloway a 23 year old native of refugio
texas marched with us when he hooked up
with us he carried on his shoulder an
m16 rifle which the Special Forces
commander major Charles Beckwith had
handed him when the fight was over
Galloway told Beckwith that strictly
speaking under the Geneva Convention he
was a civilian non-combatant Beckwith's
response no such thing in these
mountains boy take that rifle so if you
know anything about Charles Beckworth
Major Charlie Beckwith that's the guy
that created Delta Force complete badass
warrior and he was a special forces
commander in Vietnam and and was one of
the first people that apparently
Galloway worked with and Galloway said
you know you better arm yourself
so here's Galloway talking Galloway
remembers my first time out with Hal
Moore's 1st battalion 7th cavalry was a
hellish walk into the Sun to a remote
mountain guard mountain village we got
into a patch of brush and wait a minute
vine so thick and phony that every step
had to be carved out with machetes we
covered maybe 300 yards in four hours
and forwarded a fast running chest deep
mountain stream just as darkness fell
then huddled in our Poncho's wet and
freezing all night long at first light I
pinched off a small piece of c4 plastic
explosive from the emergency supply in
my pack and used it to boil up a canteen
of water for coffee if you lit c4 very
carefully you could be drinking hot
coffee and maybe 30 seconds if you were
careless it blew off your arm over a
first cigarette
I watched Moore's men first they shaved
shaved up here I was amazed then the
colonel himself blonde judge odd and
very intense a son of Bardstown Kentucky
and West Point walked by on this morning
rounds with the sergeant made with
sergeant major Plumlee Moore looked me
over and said we all shave in my outfit
reporters included my steaming coffee
water went for a wash and a shave and I
gained a measure of respect for the man
[Music]
daily disciplined in all things you know
that's another thing that I failed to
mention but it's very clear when you
read the book is this is 1965 and the
war had not escalated at all and it
wasn't the the meat grinder that it
turned into so these guys you know in
their workup all they knew that they
were going to fight but they didn't they
didn't know it wasn't the Vietnam that
we think of now where there's a lot of
casualties happening it hadn't gotten
there yet and as a matter of fact this
battle is really the first one where
that where you start seeing very
significant American casualties the guy
that's in charge over how over how more
is a guy named Colonel Brown and he
shows up going back to the
not long after Colonel Brown flew in
checked on the situation with Alpha
Company then called me aside how I'm
moving your battalion west tomorrow
morning
he said unfolding his map here is your
area of operations north of Chu pong in
the I drank Valley your mission is the
same one you have now find and kill the
enemy he rapidly outlined the scope of
operations and the resources he could
spare 16 uh-1d Huey's so that's a Huey
helicopter it's the most I guess the the
most iconic helicopter probably of any
military and certainly of Vietnam the
Huey helicopter is is completely iconic
16 Huey's to move my troops to 105
howitzer batteries within range to
support us in at least two days on the
ground patrolling
he added that Alpha Company of the 229th
helicopter alt helicopter battalion
would provide the helicopters the 229th
a company commander Major Bruce Crandall
was on his way now
one more thing how in that area be sure
your companies are close enough for
mutual support so the reason I
highlighted that a lot of times people
have a tendency in in combat situations
especially when planning to get too far
apart from each other and I would see
this all the time and what happens is it
seems to make sense because you cover
more ground or you have better angles
and it seems like a good idea like hey
we'll just split up and you can take
care of your guys and I'll take care of
my guys but you always need to stay
within a position where you can mutually
support each other where if we get in
trouble we can cover and move that
that's what it is you want to be able to
cover to move cover move so the minute
you're out of sight out of line of sight
out of radio out of the out of a
distance where your weapons can be used
to support you're alone mm-hmm that's
the thing you you get away from
line-of-sight radio contact the distance
that weapons can be shot effectively
from the other unit that you're out
there with now you are alone
so when you're planning make sure and
he's saying in that area I always use
that rule oh yeah
as often as possible are there times
where you can you can you can flex that
rule a little bit of course there are
there are situations you can get into
and you can it might be a better
tactical call but always keep in mind
what you're doing and what you're
sacrificing when you can no longer
mutually support the other units that
you're out with and they can't mutually
support you you're alone so he knows
this is going to be a little bit of a
hot area Lee seeks he suspects it going
back to the book how ready was my
battalion for combat we had never
maneuvered in combat as an entire
battalion although all three rifle
companies had been minor scrapes so
they've been in Vietnam for a while
they've been in a little bit of contact
but nothing too major and like he just
said none of them none of them had been
they had been out as a group as a
battalion back to the book most of the
men had never seen an enemy soldier dead
or alive we had killed fewer than ten
black pajama gorillas in the
get-acquainted patrols and small
operations since our arrival the four
line companies had 20 of their
authorized 23 officers but the enlisted
ranks been badly whittled down by
expiring enlistments malaria cases and
requirements for base camp guards and
workers back in NK Alpha Company had 115
men 49 fewer than authorized Bravo
Company at 114 men was 50 short Charlie
Company at 106 men down by 58 and the
weapons company Delta had only 76 men 42
fewer than authorized headquarters
company was also under strength and I
had been forced to draw it down further
by sending men out to fill crucial
medical and communications vacancies in
the line companies I didn't like being
short-handed but things had been no
different in the Korean War and somehow
we made do you just suck it up and do it
and we would do the same we do the same
way in the I dragged the officers and
NCOs would do what they could to make up
the slack just as we had done in Korea
my point in reading that these guys are
heavily under man they're supposed to
have 150 people and they have you know
100 105 whatever and there's nothing
they can do about it and it's also
interesting and worth noting that he has
a headquarters company so you got the
battalion commander and he's got a group
of guys that do weapons for him and also
communications and he's pushed those
guys out so instead of keeping those
guys and making him his his own team all
fat and happy nope he makes his team
thin and gives as much as he can to the
to the forces that are out in the field
so another good note on leadership now
they're getting ready to roll in and we
will talk about he's kind of going
through the plan a little bit here we go
back to the book I would personally land
on the first helicopter pilot to my
Bruce Crandall and Bruce Crandall is the
commander of the helicopters that are
flying them in that would permit me a
final low-level look at the landing zone
and surrounding terrain and with
Crandall in the front seat and me in the
back we could work out on the spot any
last-minute diversion to an alternate
Landers landing zone if necessary and
fix any other problems with the lift in
the American Civil War it was a matter
of principle that a good officer rode
his horse as little as possible
there were sound reasons for this if you
are riding and your soldiers are
marching how can you judge how tired
they are how thirsty how heavy their
packs weigh on their shoulders I applied
the same philosophy in Vietnam where
every battalion commander had his own
command and control helicopter some
commanders use their helicopter as their
personal mount I never believed in that
you had to get on the ground with your
troops to see and hear what was
happening you have to soak up first-hand
information for your instincts to
operate accurately besides it's too easy
to be crisp cool and detached at 1,500
feet too easy to demand the impossible
of your troops too easy to make mistakes
that are fatal only to those souls far
below in the mud the blood and confusion
so this is something we talk about all
the time from a leadership perspective
you cannot be you know it's it's the
it's the icon
detachment right it does pay and there
are certain times where you can tell in
in these situations if you're in the
command helicopter that's up above the
fighting well your your de facto I mean
you you are detached from the situation
and you can see what's happening you
have you have a good view of what's
going on but even though you have a good
view you're also missing a bunch you're
missing what it's like down there you're
missing what the men are seeing you're
missing what it looks like to them
you're missing the communication
breakdowns that are happening down there
so you have to find that balance between
these two and and he clearly is aware of
that he's preparing for this he's got a
bull a book called street without joy by
a guy named Bernard fall and it's it's a
book about Vietnam it's a book about the
the tragedy that the French troops went
through fighting the Vietnamese and he
says that he took one lesson away from
that book and this is the lesson death
is the price you pay for under
estimating this tenacious enemy so he
was aware and like general mattis said
you know not too long ago they're
talking about general mattis and how
come you read so many books and he says
because I get to see I get to learn and
this is a classic case he he knew he
read books about the the French that had
fought the Vietnamese what ten years
earlier 11 years earlier and that made
him more prepared now talking a little
bit like I said there's a there's great
information in here about the enemy and
like I said they went and interviewed
and got reports from the enemy and here
we go a little bit about the enemy back
to the book the soldiers commanded by
Brigadier General Chu Huey man had been
training for more than 18 months when
they joined the People's Army each
recruit was issued to khaki shirts two
pairs of khaki trousers a sewing kit and
a pair of Ho Chi Minh sandals cut from
used tire trucks those uniforms were
expected to last
five years basic training lasted 13
weeks 6 days a week 6 a.m. to 9:15 p.m.
the instructors emphasized weapons and
tactics the House of warfare while the
political commissary had time had time
set aside each day to lecture on the
whys of this war the recruits were
reminded constantly that their fathers
had beaten the French colonialists now
it was their duty to defeat the American
imperialists they were imbued with Ho
Chi Minh's dictum nothing is more
precious than freedom and independence
after basic training some were selected
for six months of NCO school and would
emerge as new corporals for the rest
advanced infantry training included
familiarization with all weapons the use
of explosive ambush tactics
reconnaissance tactics adjusting mortar
fire and patrol tactics in June of 1964
man soldiers moved up into the mountains
of North Vietnam on Vietnam terrain
similar to that in western highlands of
South Vietnam here physical conditioning
was emphasized they scaled steep slopes
while wearing ruck sacks loaded with 50
to 60 pounds of rocks their advanced
training now also focused on the art of
camouflage when the time came for them
to begin the arduous two-month journey
down the Ho Chi Minh Trail through Laos
general Mann's regiment broke down into
battalions for security purposes each
moving separately at least three days
ahead of the next each soldier carried
four pounds of rice seven days rations
plus another 8 pounds of foodstuffs that
were expected to last him the whole trip
2 pounds of salt 2 pounds of wheat flour
and 4 pounds of salt pork one man in
every squad carried the aluminium cook
pot that would that the squad's rice
would be boiled in each man also carried
50 anti malaria pills one for each day
on the trail and a hundred vitamin b1
tabs to be taken at the rate of three
per week despite the pills virtually
every man who walked the trail
contracted malaria and on average three
or four soldiers of each 160 man company
would die on the journey malaria
diarrhea accidents poisonous snakes and
American air raids took their toll
man's soldiers marched nine miles each
day the distance between rest camps
where they spent each night every day
every fourth day they stayed in camp
taking the day off to rest up wash their
clothes and tend to minor medical
problems so this is a legit enemy mmm
we're looking at legit enemy organized
well-trained hard tough well led and and
ready and you can't ever you know this
is one of the biggest problems with
fighting a counterinsurgency is you're
going against someone that's fighting on
their home turf and that is just you
can't see how do you overcome that
advantage well you overcome that
advantage with firepower and with some
technology but that is a hard advantage
to overcome yeah and here's a quote from
general an when you landed there you
landed right in the middle of three of
our battalions of the 66th regiment our
service our reserve force it was the
strongest we had at full strength the
battalions each had about 450 men also
there was a headquarters battalion the
regiment's total strength was about
1,600 men so they're kind of by chance
set up on the same spot where these guys
are gonna go in which is LZ x-ray
landing zone x-ray and here these
they're flying in into the LZ x-ray
captain john heron who's Bravo Company
troops filled the helicopter recalls it
was a cool it was a misty cool morning
with some low-hanging fog when we lifted
off but shortly after takeoff we broke
into the clear and you could see the 105
artillery pounding the areas around the
LZ as we headed in Vietnam even in war
was scenic with green jungle heavy
forested mountains and wild looking
rivers criss-crossing the terrain now
the helicopters of the aerial rocket
artillery slammed the perimeter with
rockets grenades and machine-gun fire
using 24 of the
48 2.7 inch rockets they carried so it's
the it's the same thing that we've heard
before its cover move right as you come
into a landing zone like they did in
d-day what do you do first you bomb the
crap out of it
you hit it with naval gunfire and
they're doing the same thing here
they're prepping the landing zone by
dropping a bunch of 105 howitzers into
the around the surrounding area around
the landing zone and then the
helicopters once it's too close and the
and the howitzers have to turn off then
the helicopters start shooting and they
do their best to clear of the area
around the landing zone that's what's
going on
back to the book the People's Army
commander on the battlefield then Senior
Lieutenant Colonel UN who on says when
you drop troops into x-ray I was on to
pong mountain we had a very strong
position and a strong mobile command
group we were ready we were ready had
prepared for you and expected you to
come the only question was when the
trees and bush limited our view of the
helicopters landing but we had an
observation post on top of the mountain
and they reported to us when you drop
troops and when you move them so you
know I talk about all the time about
having the high ground well when these
guys are landing in a valley mm-hmm and
they're surrounded by hanging high
ground so it's a your adil you're at a
tactical disadvantage there right as
soon as just about as soon as they hit
the ground they're there for a little
while and they get a prisoner the the
Americans get a prisoner and here's
there's a translator and he translates
the prisoners words and here's what the
prisoner says or here's what the
translator says he says there are three
battalions on the mountain who want very
much to kill Americans but have not been
able to find any now you take that with
a grain of salt because it's coming from
a prisoner but it's not nothing I'll put
it to you that way it's something back
to the books only a few rifle shots rang
out in the area where the prisoner had
been captured
sergeant Gil Roth's men were in contact
it was now 12:15 p.m. we had to move
fast if we were going to survive had
get off the landing zone and hit them
before they could hit us only if we
brought the enemy to battle deep in the
trees and brush
could we stand even a slim chance of
holding on to the clearing and getting
the rest of the battalion landed that
football-field-sized clearing was our
lifeline and our supply line if the
enemy closed the way to the helicopters
all of us would die in this place so
that's one of the or the hard things
about helicopter warfare especially in
Vietnam well actually anywhere is you
gets great you can go a long distance
and get in there but then once you're
there there's if the helicopters can't
come get you out or they can't resupply
you you're in real problem you're you're
back to the word that I said earlier
you're alone yeah back to the book even
as the first shots rang out I was
raiding Ewing Heron to saddle up the
rest of Bravo Company the rest of his
his Bravo Company men to move out fast
toward the mountain to develop the
situation turning to Nadal and he's
again I there's all these characters I
mean there's there's all the company
commanders the platoon commanders the
the platoon leaders the platoon
sergeants there's the ground troops
there's all these characters and and the
book does an outstanding job of
detailing who all these individuals were
what their background was where they
came from and I just don't we can't do
that right now but that's why you buy
the book and you read the book but this
guy in the doll is one of the company
commanders so here we go turning to
Nadal I told him that the original plan
was out the window that his Alpha
Company should immediately take over LC
security and get ready to move up on
Bravo companies left when Charlie when
enough of Charlie Company and arrived on
the next lift to assume the job of
securing and clearing so classic you hit
the ground and and now all of a sudden
the plan is out the window right out the
window we're going with our standard
operating procedures which is hey we're
gonna move a company here you're gonna
set up perimeter security and go back to
the book in a small cops the other two
platoon platoons of Bravo Company men
had opened c-ration cans and we're
grabbing a bite when they heard the
first shots in the brush the older
sergeants glanced at one another nodded
eat fast they told the men and get ready
to move
the Battle of LZ x-ray had just begun
and it it doesn't take long to begin
going back to the book says sergeant
Gilreath we were virtually pinned to the
ground and taking casualties lieutenant
Dennis Diehl remembers that moment
davines platoon was taking moderate fire
we could all hear it through the foliage
and I heard it crackling on my radio
owl was in some sort of trouble the
firing increased in volume and intensity
then I saw my first wounded trooper
probably the first American wounded in
LZ x-ray he was shot in the neck or
mouth or both was still carrying his
rifle was ambulatory and appeared
stunned at what had happened to him when
he asked where to go I put my arm around
him and pointed to where I had last seen
the battalion commander so it's
immediately on and and you of course it
is because there's there's three
battalions of Vietnamese soldiers there
and this is this is how more talking
back to the book the military historian
SLA Marshall wrote that at the beginning
of a battle units fractionalized groping
between the antagonists takes place and
the battle takes form from all of this
Marshall had it right that is precisely
what was happening up in the scrub brush
above above landing zone x-ray this day
and no other single event would have
greater impact on the shape of this
battle than what lieutenant Henry
Herrick was in the process of doing
Herrick charged right past lieutenant
davines men swung his platoon to the
right in hot pursuit of a few fleeting
em enemy soldiers and disappeared from
sight into the bush says sergeant Ernie
Savage of Herricks orders he made a bad
decision and we knew at the time it was
a bad decision we were breaking contact
with the rest of the company we were
supposed to come up on the flank of
first Platoon in fact we were moving
away from them we lost contact with
everyone everybody so again this is what
I just talked about and it's you're
gonna see throughout this book
all these principles that we talk about
all the time that that we taught and
that we live through you can see that
these types of things happen and here's
a classic thing I was just talking about
like when you get out of distance from
your supporting elements you're now
alone mm-hmm
and that's a bad situation to be in back
to the book now John Heron was up on my
radio reporting that his men were under
heavy attack by at least two enemy
companies and that his second platoon
was in danger of being surrounded and
cut off from the rest of the company
even as he spoke modern rocket rounds
hid in the clearing where I stood my
worst case scenario had just come to
pass we are now in heavy contact before
all my battalion was on the ground and
now I had to deal with a cut off platoon
my response was an angry [__] captain
Captain John herons estimate that his
Bravo Company men were trying to deal
with two enemy companies was slightly
off one full enemy battalion more than
500 determined enemy soldiers was
boiling down the mountain toward Herrick
strapped 2nd platoon and maneuvering
near Aldo Vinny's pinned down 1st
platoon again here's something that I
failed to talk about with helicopter
warfare so he's got a battalion of 500
guys 550 guys hmm you can't fit all
those guys on 16 helicopters so you've
got to do multiple laps and that's what
he's he's worried he was worried about
it going in that hey I want to get my
whole battalion on the ground before the
fighting starts he's already failed to
do that or maybe he hasn't failed to do
it but it didn't happen
back to the book I was tempted to join
the dolls or Edwards men but resisted
the temptation I had no business getting
involved with the actions of only one
company I might get pinned down and
simply become another rifleman my duty
was to lead riflemen so there's a you
know we talked about the detachment that
he said hey look I'm not gonna be up in
the helicopter
but right now he's saying look I'm not
gonna be in a helicopter overhead at
1,500 feet but I'm not gonna be sitting
in a platoon as a rifleman slugging it
out with the enemy that's not the right
place to be either you have
in order to lead you have to take a step
back you have to detach and he does that
to the best of his ability then here we
go back to the book just now the snaps
and cracks of the rounds passing nearby
took on a distinctly different sound
like a swarm of bees around our heads I
was on the radio trying to hear a
transmission over the noise when I felt
the firm hand on my right soldier
shoulder
it was sergeant major Plumlee's he
shouted over the racket of the firefight
sir if you don't find some cover you're
gonna go down and if you go down we all
go down
Plumlee was right as always anyone
waving yelling hand signaling or talking
on the radio was instantly targeted by
the enemy
these guys were quick to spot and shoot
leaders radio operators and medics I had
never fretted about being wounded in
combat in Korea or here but Plumlee
brought me up short the game was just
beginning this was no time for me to go
out of it the sergeant major pointed to
a large termite hill six or seven feet
high located in some trees in the wastes
between the two open areas of the
landing zone it was about 30 yards away
and three of us turned and ran toward it
with bullets kicking up red dirt around
our feet and the bees still buzzing
around our heads that termite hill the
size of a large automobile would become
the battalion command post the aid
station the supply point the collection
area for enemy prisoners weapons and
equipment and the place where our dead
were brought casualties were now
beginning to pile up as we drop behind
that termite hill I fleetingly thought
about an illustration an illustrious
predecessor of mine in the seventh
Cavalry Lieutenant Colonel George
Armstrong Custer and his final stay
stand in the valley of Little Bighorn in
Montana 89 years earlier I was
determined that history would not repeat
itself in the valley of the eyed rang we
were a tight well trained and
disciplined fighting force and we had
one thing George Custer did not have
fire support
fire-support plays it it's an it's
beyond critical I mean they would not
have been able to do this without fire
support and that's the one thing that's
gonna save them I mean obviously the
discipline obviously the training
obviously the bravery but the fire
support is is a gift mm-hmm back to the
book sergeant Steve Hanson was behind
and to the right of Lieutenant Taft he
says we moved at a trot across the open
grass toward the tree line and heard
fire up on the finger to the west where
we were headed my radio operator friend
specialist for Ray Turner ray Tanner and
I crossed the stream bed captain Nadal's
party and the two other platoons were
off to the right lieutenant Taft was
well forward as we crossed over into the
trees sergeant first class Lorenzo
Nathan Ray Turner and I were close maybe
10 yards behind we were moving fast
specialists speck for peat winter was
near me we ran into a wall of lead every
man in the lead squad was shot from the
time we got the order to move to the
time where men were dying was only 5
minutes the enemy were very close to us
and over ran some of our dead the firing
was heavy sergeant Nathan pulled us back
out of the woods of the streambed Bob
Hazen Bob TAFEs radio operator recalls
lieutenant Taft got out in front of me I
was off to his left he added he had his
rady he had the radio handset in his
left hand connected to the radio on my
back with that flux and flexible rubber
wire it got tight and I pulled back on
the lieutenant and hollered we're
getting off line he glanced back at me
turned back to his front and took four
more steps then he fired two shots at
something I couldn't see what then he
dropped facedown on the ground
lieutenant Taft was hit I didn't realize
how bad until I rolled him over he was
shot in the throat and the rounded
ricocheted down and come out his left
side he was dead and it was difficult to
roll him over even though he was a slave
built man captain Nadal says the enemy
on the mountain started moving down
rapidly in somewhat uncoordinated
attacks they streamed down the hill and
down the creek bed the enemy knew the
area they came down the best covered
route the 3rd platoon was heavily
engaged and the volume of firing reached
a crescendo on my left at this time I
lost con radio contact with Taft platoon
in the center of that fury Bob Hazen
struggled and rolled his dead platoon
leader over he was gone and there was
nothing we could do the first thing I
thought of was what they've taught me
never let the enemy get his hands on a
map or the signals codebook I got those
from lieutenant Taft and was kneeling
over to try and pull his body back
that's when my radio was hit and the
shrapnel from the radio hit me in the
back of the head it didn't really hurt
all the sudden I was just laying face
down on the ground next to lieutenant
Taft
I felt something running down my treeck
but down my neck reached back and came
out with a handful of blood
Carman Miceli was on Hazen's right we
knew what had happened the word passed
fast they got lieutenant Taft again
we're talking within minutes of these
guys arriving this is two going
completely sideways back to the book
captain the doll out of radio contact
with taps platoon moved moved toward the
furious firing on his left flank to find
out what was happening Nadal says my
radio operator sergeant Jack Eagle the
company communications chief who had
volunteered to carry one of my two
radios ran with me out from out of the
creek bed and into the open area toward
Taft's position we ran into sergeant
Nathan and I asked him what was
happening he said the platoon had been
attacked on the left flank the left
squad had taken a number of casualties
and had pulled back out of the creek bed
refusing their left enemy their left
flank to the enemy Nathan said Taft had
been hit and was left in the creek bed
that made me angry we had been taught
never to leave any wounded or dead on
the battlefield
sergeant Gale and I crawled forward of
our
lines to that creek bed where the enemy
were to find Taft we came under grenade
attack from the west side of the creek
bed but had some cover from a few trees
we located Taft dead while bringing him
back we saw another soldier who had been
left behind after leaving caps body with
his platoon gal and I went back again
and we picked up the other man
back to the book Denis deal remembers we
moved online for about a hundred or 150
yards before the volume of firing forced
us to stop we were taking too many
casualties i radioed Herricks platoon
and said i think we're getting close to
you shoot one round off wait to the
count of three and shoot two more the
radioman or whoever was on the radio did
that so we had a pretty good fix on
where he was we got up and started the
assault again we went about ten yards
and the whole thing just blew in our
faces blew up in our faces the enemy had
infiltrated between Herricks platoon and
us and now we're starting to come behind
us so that platoon that had gotten
separated this element with Dennis deal
was going out to try and get contact
with him and bring him back inside the
perimeter they meet they date their
assaulting they go 100 yards 150 yards
and they start getting mowed down and
now they realize that in between they've
got bad guys in between where Herricks
platoon is and where the rest of the
perimeter is set up because they do have
kind of a rough perimeter on this on
this landing zone in the landing zone
apologize for not explaining this I mean
in order to bring in helicopters in the
jungle you need some open space so the
landing zone LZ x-ray has an area where
there's not much of foliage for whatever
reason and so that's where they've kind
of consolidated their forces only
because they can't go anywhere else they
hit the ground they start getting shot
at so now they're setting up what's
called a perimeter and obviously
Herricks platoon is outside the
perimeter back to the book lieutenant
deal adds that he and another he and the
other two platoon leaders now began
planning yet another attempt to break
through and rescue Herricks men leaders
were running back and forth coordinating
when all the sudden firing began the
lull dissipated quickly it was at this
time my weapon squad leader sergeant
Currie the chief was killed his last
words were those bastards are trying to
get me
he was caught rolling around on the
ground later on as my men were carrying
him back I had them put him down and
turned his face toward me
and looked at him I could not conceive
of
chief being dead Staff Sergeant Wilbur
Curie jr. of Buffalo New York was 35
years old
Herrick and the other two squads were
holding precariously to the small Knoll
near the bottom of the finger savage so
a a kid named savage is out there with
Herricks platoon and he ends up running
a lot of stuff and you'll find that out
but here here we start hearing a little
bit of him right now
savage teamed up with McHenry squad
which was pinned to the ground Herrick
was with that squad sergeant Valens
squad was off to the left rear savage
checked on his men when he tied up with
McHenry he knew that spec for Robert M
Hill m79 Grenadier was no longer with
them he got killed in there somewhere
he had his m79 and a 45 caliber pistol
and he was firing both at the same time
the 23 year old hill came from
Starkville Mississippi and here's
sergeant savage talking explaining some
more back to the book the enemy was past
the machine gun before it ever quit
firing I could hear sergeant hurtle down
there cursing even more even over the
firefight I heard him he was famous for
that [__] son of a [__] I could
hear him hollering that down there when
they through then they threw grenades on
him hurdle 36 was from Washington DC
baron bomb 24 was a native of New York
City PFC Donald rowdy 22 hailed from Ann
Arbor Michigan the three of them died in
a hail of rifle fire and enemy grenades
the enemy down below turned surgeon
hurdles m60 around and began using it on
the Americans on the knoll so that
causes all kinds of confusion you can
tell the difference between different
types of weapons by the way they sound
when they shoot and when someone starts
shooting a friendly weapon at you it
causes a lot of confusion and the m60 is
a beast of a weapon
belt-fed machine gun and it's when I've
gotten the SEAL Teams that was the that
was the machine gun that that we used
was the m60 machine gun and it's a
devastating weapon back to the book the
enemy more than 150 strong now attacked
the knoll from three sides north south
and east and soldiers on both sides were
falling
lieutenant Herrick ran from trooper to
trooper trying to get a defense
organized an enemy volley cut across
Herrick his radio operator specialist
John R Stewart and the three reeked and
the artillery recon sergeant sergeant
John T Brown wounding all three Herrick
and Browne seriously Stewart took a
single bullet through the leg Herrick
radioed Bravo Company Commander John
Herron and told him he had been hit and
he was turning command of the platoon
over to sergeant Carl Palmer Eric then
gave explicit instructions to his men to
destroy the signals codes redistribute
the ammunition and call an artillery and
if possible make a break for it
Herron says I give Herrick all the
credit in the world for pulling that
platoon together so they could make
their stand so should we all savage ands
Allen paint a clear picture of a green
young lieutenant who did a superb job in
a hailstorm of enemy fire his platoon
stopped the very large North Vietnamese
unit clearly heading down to join the
attack on the landing zone i long ago
concluded that the very presence of this
platoon so far to the northwest confused
the enemy commander as to exactly where
we were and how far we had penetrated in
all directions and thus helped us helped
us as the battle built sergeant savage
recounts the final moments of Henry
Herricks life he was lying beside me on
the hill and he said if I have to die
I'm glad to give my life for my country
I remember him saying that he was going
into shock
hit in the hip and in a lot of pain he
didn't live long he died early in the
fight next to a little brush pile speck
for Charles Arlo's 22 of mobile ammo
Alabama was the new platoon medic
he joined a platoon only a few days
earlier lieutenant Herrick was kneeling
when hit he had a bullet wound to the
hip he told me to go help the other
wounded yeah
it's we have to remember that this guy
Herrick is like 22 23 year old fresh out
of him he's a first he might even be 21
and he made that majorly offensive move
and pursued and gone out of touch but
what how Moore is saying hey that
confused the enemy even though it
confused the friendlies do it confused
the enemy as well so there's some
there's some good that came out of it
back to the book sergeant Rueben Thomas
was struck by a bullet above his heart
that exited under his left arm bleeding
heavily he grabbed a rifle and fought on
the encircled infantrymen of the lost
platoon refused to give up here's what
specialist doorman said we were all on
the ground now and if you moved you got
hit our training really showed then we
shifted into defensive positions we had
five men killed in 25 minutes then all
of a sudden they try to mass assault
from three directions rushing from Bush
to Bush laying fire on us we put our hem
16s on full automatic and have killed
most of them another guy named Galen
bung-bung bung-bung um said we gathered
up all the full magazines we could find
and stacked them up in front of us there
was no way we could dig a foxhole the
handle was blown off my entrenching tool
and one of my canteens had a hole blown
through it the fire was so heavy that if
he tried to raise up to dig you were
dead there was death and destruction all
around by now eight men of the platoons
29 have been killed in action another 13
were wounded the 25 yard wide perimeter
was a circle of pain death fear and raw
courage medic Charlie Lowe's crawled
from man to man throughout the rage and
firefight doing his best to patch the
wounded with limited supplies in his
medical pack
although he himself was wounded twice
Lowe's never slowed his pace he would
keep all 13 of the wounded alive for the
426 long harrowing hours Lowe's says on
several occasions I had to stand or sit
up to treat the wounded each time the VC
fired heavily at me Lowe's used his 45
and m16 rifle to help defend his
patients of getting attacked from three
sides thirteen wounded eight dead was it
nine dead unbelievable
back to the book command had passed so
this is talking about you know when
someone if the leader gets killed it
goes to the next person
that person gets killed it goes the next
person so here's what's happening in
Herricks platoon the lost platoon back
to the book command had passed from
lieutenant Henry Herrick to sergeant
Carl Palmer to sergeant Robert Stokes
and each in turn
died fighting now it was the turn of
Buck sergeant Ernie Savage sergeant
savage came up on the radio
captain Herron recalls he said Herrick
Palmer and Stokes were dead to give him
more artillery and he would direct it in
as close as possible we could never
establish the platoons exact position
but lieutenant riddle could have just
fire on savages sensing and he began to
do that the extraordinary unyielding
resistance that the dozen or so
effective fighting fighters were putting
up plus the artillery barrages that
Ernie savage was bringing down finally
beat off the heavy enemy attack
Ernie Savage and his small band hunkered
down determined to hold their ground to
the end yeah and these guys are calling
in to Danger Close if we were talking
about Danger Close
no no Kay Danger Close is when you're
calling in fire support and you want it
to be very close to where you are and
you on the ground have to take
responsibility for it so in other words
the the person whether it's artillery or
whether it's aircraft
you have to call and say danger-close
yes send the rounds we know it's close
it's we take responsibility for what
happens hmm and by the way going back to
the book as this fifth left lift of the
day roared out at treetop level the
landing zone will suddenly turned
red-hot so they haven't even landed
everyone yet this is going on they
haven't gotten everyone on the landing
zone yet
and here's Crandall talking and again
he's the the pilot unbelievably heroic
pilot and commanding officer of this
helicopter unit says Crandall as I was
flaring out to touchdown we started
receiving heavy heavy ground fire I had
three dead and three wounded on my bird
the wounded included my crew chief who
had been hit in the throat when we
landed we saw that every bullet had
struck the wounded in the head or neck
excellent marksmanship by the other side
and not a happy thought for a helicopter
pilot to say the least
so the enemy's taken headshots back to
the book with Crandall flying serpent
yellow three where Chief Warrant
officers Ricardo J Lombardo 34 of
Hartford Connecticut and Alex s pop
Jekyll 43 of Seattle Washington pop
Jekyll was a father of nine children
during World War two at the age of
twenty he had flown b-24s out of England
and b-29s during the post-war years
until he left the service in 1950 pop
Jekyll re-enlisted in 1952 and had been
flying helicopters since 1963 pop Jekyll
keyed the intercom and said I flew 31
missions in in b-24s in World War two
and that's the closest I've ever come to
swallowing my balls so these these
landing zones were crazy with these
helicopter pilots flying in there it's a
it's you're here you're getting there as
fast as you can but there's not much you
can do you know you bring it in as fast
as you can you try and get loaded up
quick and you try and take off but it's
not like you're able to shoot back even
once you're on the ground your machine
gunners in the Huey's they can't shoot
anymore because you don't know where the
friendly troops are so you're a sitting
duck literally a sitting duck and these
pilots going in time and time and time
again this goes to the Delta company
commander Lefebvre and here's what's
going on Lefebvre seriously wounded was
phasing was fading fast I had lost a lot
of blood I could see people shooting but
I couldn't hear any sounds anymore I
told John Heron somebody had to take
over I called again Colonel Moore and
told him that I was going to turn over
the company to sergeant Gonzales then
the medic arrived to bandaged my wounds
after I remember someone putting me in a
poncho and hauling me over to the area
of the battalion command post when I saw
a lieutenant - Bona again later we never
did talk much about it it was just too
damn close to the real thing ray
Lefebvre and his handful of Delta
Company troopers had unknowingly joined
the Alpha Company flight at a crucial
moment about 30 North Vietnamese were
flanking Nadal's men on their left and
captain Lefevre the febris party ran
smack into them and killed most of them
the dolls men dispatched the rest
unknown to Lefevre sergeant Gonzales had
been hit in the face by an enemy bullet
Gonzales simply said Rodger when Lefevre
told him he was now in command and for
the next half hour and a half
he ran Delta Company sergeant Gonzales
shot in the face no factor I mean is
still going to take leadership right now
going back to the book it was during all
this horror that Beck remembers fear
coming over him and hears back talking
while doc null was here with me working
on Russell fear real fear hit me fear
like I had never known before
fear comes and once you recognize it and
accept that it passes just as fast as it
comes and you really don't have to think
about it anymore
you just do what you have to do but you
learn the real meaning of fear and life
and death for the next two hours I was
alone on that gun shooting the enemy
anymore shooting at me and bullets were
hitting the ground beside me and
cracking above my head they were
attacking me and I fired as fast as I
could in long bursts my m60 was cooking
I had to take a crap and a leak bad so I
pulled my pants down while laying on my
side and did it on my side taking fire
at the time now we're going back to how
more talking here from my command post
at the termite hill the enemy were
clearly visible 100 yards to the south
they were damned good soldiers used
covered concealment to perfection and
were deadly shots most of my dead and
wounded soldiers had been shot in the
head or upper body
the North Vietnamese pay particular
attention to radio operators and leaders
they did not appear to have radios
themselves they controlled their men by
shouts waves pointing whistles and
sometimes bugle calls it was 2:45 p.m.
all three of my rifle companies were
heavily engaged we had lost the use of
the larger clearing for the helicopter
landings wounded were streaming into the
command post aid station we were in a
desperate fix and I was worried that it
could become even more desperate by now
I believed we were fighting at least two
people's armies battalions turns out it
was three they were very determined to
wipe us out but a major difference
between Lieutenant Colonel when who on
of the People's Army of Vietnam and
Lieutenant Colonel how more of the 1st
Cavalry Division was that I had major
fire support and he didn't Air Force
captain Bruce Wallace and his fellow a1
Skyraider pilots as well as the jet
fighter bombers from all three services
helped provide that edge flying 50
sorties in close air support that Sunday
afternoon says Wallace the importance of
airplanes in a vulgar brawl is to be
down among the palm trees with the
troops putting ordnance on the ground at
the exact time in the precise place that
the ground command needs it and then so
he there in these old school sky Raiders
but then captain Wallace is talking
about what it was like watching the
helicopters back to the book with it it
was different with a Huey to watch for a
to them at a time maneuvering up and
down and laterally and even backwards
boggles the fighter pilots mind those
guys swarm a target like bees over honey
I had to hand it to those Huey guys they
really got down there in the
with the troops then this is Hal mer Hal
more talking again the field artillery
what we call tube artillery to
distinguish howitzer folks from the
helicopter rocket folks proudly calls
itself the king of battle the brave
cannon cockers and LZ Falcon went
without sleep for three days and three
nights to help keep us surrounded by a
wall of Steel those two batteries twelve
guns fired more than four thousand
rounds of high-explosive shells on the
first day alone says Barker on the first
afternoon both batteries fired for
effect directly on target for five
straight hours one of Bruce krandalls
huey slick pilots captain paul Winkle
touched down at falcon briefly that at
first afternoon and was astounded by
what he saw there were stacks of shell
casings at least ten feet high and
exhausted gun crews they had fired for
effect for three state straight hours by
then without even pausing to level the
bubbles one tube was burned out two it
busted hydraulics that's some shooting
no matter how bad things got for
Americans fighting for their lives on
the xray perimeter we can look out to
the scrub brush in every direction into
that seething inferno of exploding
artillery shells 2.75 inch rockets
napalm canisters 250 and 500 pound bombs
and 20 millimeter cannon fire and thank
God and our lucky stars that we didn't
have to walk through that to get to work
yeah so like I said the the close air
support is absolutely or the close air
support the artillery is absolutely what
and that's that's been happened many on
many occasions for for American soldiers
sailors Marines overseas fighting you
know the Air Force the Navy pilots the
Marine Corps fire
pilots coming in and actually the guy on
the ground controlling these guys is a
Air Force pilot as well so having that
air superiority is a wonderful thing now
speaking of the Aviators going back to
the helicopters
chapter 9 in this book is called brave
aviators in it again his sitting ducks
coming in is crazy to read about going
back to the book over the 20 months of
airmobile training a bond had been
welded between the infantry and their
rides the Huey helicopter pilots and
crewmen now the strength of that bond
will be tested in the hottest of fires
if the air bridge failed so the meaning
the helicopters ability to gain there if
the air bridge failed the embattled men
of 1st battalion 7th calves would
certainly die in much the same way
George Armstrong Custer's cavalry men
died at Little Bighorn caught off
surrounded by numerically superior
forces overrun and butchered to the last
man I asked Bruce can't krandalls brave
air crews of Alpha Company the 229th
aviation battalion for the last measure
of devotion for service far beyond the
limits of duty and mission and they came
through as I knew they would and that so
so again you're basically asking these
guys to get shot down every time they
fly in and this is interesting
back to the book this was early in the
war and the medevac commanders had
decreed that their birds would not land
in hot landing zones in other words that
they would not go where they were needed
when when they were needed the most
even before I asked Bruce Crandall that
our decided to begin doing everything
that had to be done staying with it
Crandall now dropped this Huey loaded
with casualties onto the red dirt strip
when we and this is this is Grand
Crandall talkin when we hit the ground
we were met by medics and infantry
troops still waiting to be lifted into
x-ray so that's another crazy thing to
think about you're you're unloading
wounded men and you're and you're
getting on that aircraft that's gonna go
pick up more men but you're going to
stay so the troops that aren't on the
ground yet think about what's going
through their minds they may remove the
dead and you want to know what's going
through their minds I actually actually
know what's going through their mind
they're going most of those guys are
saying get me in there as fast as you
can that's what they're saying these are
their brothers out there
back to the book they removed the dead
and wounded from my bird and this act is
engraved in my mind deeper than any
other experience in my two tours in
Vietnam a huge black enlisted man clad
only in shorts and boots hands bigger
than dinner plates reached into my
helicopter to pick up one of the dead
white soldiers he had tears streaming
down his face and he tenderly created
cradled that dead soldier to his chest
as he walked slowly from the aircraft to
the medical station I never knew if the
man he picked up was his buddy or not I
suspect not his grief was for a fallen
comrade and for the agony that violent
death brings to those who witness it
more about the helicopters back to the
book one of the ships brought in larry
linton who immediately took over command
of Delta Company from the wounded
sergeant Gonzales I told him to add the
four Delta mortars to consolidate mortar
position set up by captain Edwards and
to control all seven mortars from a
single fire Direction center principal
direction of fire was towards alpha and
Bravo companies and the mortar men would
also have the mission of defending our
two chopper landing zones least the
reason I highlighted that is even though
I talk about decentralized command all
the time and how more starts off the
book talking about how important
decentralized command is he's right now
in that in that moment he's centralizing
command he needs to get control of all
the mortars so that they can use it
correctly so again that's why it's the
dichotomy of leadership because you can
there's times when you most the time you
decentralized but you can actually
decentralized too much and if you don't
coordinate the efforts of these mortars
you're not going to use them effectively
so he centralizes the command of the
mortars brings them all into one
location and starts using them
effectively so that's a good note for
leaders to remember
now here's another platoon commander Joe
marm Joe marm describes the situation in
his platoon my platoon medic was a
short-timer and did not accompany us to
chew pong sergeant first class George
McCauley the platoon sergeant carried
the aid kit and we plan to use Staff
Sergeant Thomas Tolliver as our medic
when the need arose he had been a combat
medic during the Korean War and was well
qualified still we did not have enough
medics to go around so we sent down
specialist Buch Knight and specialist
Charles Lowe's a senior medical aid man
as platoon medics to Bravo Company now
Calvin Boop night still alive but
mortally wounded was laid gently on the
ground and his blood filled rubber
poncho before the medical platoon
sergeant sergeant first class Keaton his
friend and comrade for the last two
years and here's what Keaton says Buch
Knight wasn't dead he was shot right
between the soldiers right directly
between the sole shoulders he reached up
and took my hand and said Sarge I didn't
make it
we got an IV started on him and put a
pressure bandage over his back wound
there was just no hope we were able to
get him on an evac ship but he died the
scriptures say that there is no greater
love than to lay down your life for your
friends this is what Calvin book Knight
did in that fire filled jungle he
sheltered the wounded he was treating
with his own body his back to the enemy
guns completely vulnerable
and here's how more it was now 3:45 p.m.
and except for the predicament of
Sergeant Savage and the cutoff platoon I
was feeling a good deal better about the
situation we had all of our men in
massive firepower had been deployed a
company of reinforcements was on the way
our two chopper lifeline landing zone
was secure most of our wounded were
either evacuated or awaiting evacuation
and we were holding tough I was
determined to make one more attempt to
rescue sergeant savage and all his
wounded and dead on the slope I ordered
alpha and Bravo companies to evacuate
their casualties withdraw out of close
contact with the enemy under covering
fires and prepare to launch a
coordinated attack supported by heavy
prepare to worry artillery fire to reach
the cutoff platoon I was tortured by the
fate of those men and the need to rescue
them in chapter 10 is called fix
bayonets which can give you an
indication back to the book alpha and
Bravo companies the first units to land
had now been locked in violent battle
for more than two hours had suffered no
small number of casualties especially
among the sergeants and radio operators
and it shot up most of their ammunition
that's another thing we got to remember
the movies they never run out of
ammunition right unless it makes some
theatrical point yet plot point right
they also in the movies there's plenty
of water oh they're in the jungle they
got plenty water these guys don't have
water out here mmm no water no food and
now they're running out of ammunition
the two commanders Toni Nadal and Jon
Herron needed time to evacuate they're
dead and wounded to reorganize and
regroup their diminished platoons and
designate new leaders and to replenish
stocks of ammunitions of ammunition and
grenades they would have 40 minutes to
accomplish this then heavy artillery
fire would lain down ahead of them as
they kicked off one more attempt to
break through the ring of enemy troops
and rescue the survivors of lieutenant
Henry Herrick 2nd platoon meanwhile help
was on the way back at 3rd brigade
headquarters in the tea plantation the
orders were going out our sister
battalion the 2nd battalion 7th
that one of its companies Bravo was
being detached and sent to landing x-ray
landing zone x-ray to reinforce on
arrival in x-ray Bravo Company 2nd
battalion would come under my
operational control for the duration of
the fight so there's a there's two
battalions each battalion has a number
of companies in them and they're gonna
take one of the companies from the other
battalion and let him let them come in
as reinforcements captain Myron did
Urich Bravo Company troops won the toss
hand down so the there was a bunch of
different companies there and they were
all doing various things but Myron did
Derek's company was actually I think
they were they were standing guard or
they were closest by and so they're the
ones that were going and it's it's it's
probably a good thing because this guy
captain Derek is a complete badass as
Woolsey Bravo Company 2nd battalion had
good solid professional non comms and
it's troop had served together for some
for a long time it was a good rifle
company I was happy to get it captain -
Derek was 27 years old a native-born
Ukrainian who had come to the United
States with his family in 1950 he was an
ROTC graduate from st. Peter's College
in in Jersey City New Jersey and was
commissioned in July of 1960 he
completed paratrooper and Ranger
training and had served tours in Germany
and at Fort Benning diderik was married
and the father of two children while our
reinforcements were saddling up my alpha
and Bravo companies were about to launch
their second attempt to break through to
lieutenant Herrick strapped lateen John
Herron and Toni Nadal had pulled their
men back to the dry creek bed during the
law so they would begin they attack from
their platoon sergeant Troy Miller
remembers the scene our morale was very
high after the first contact before we
went off before we went after the
colonel attuned captain Nadal got us
together and said men we've got an
American platoon caught off out there
and we're going after them the replies
word yeah and let's go get them at Gary
Owen and Gary Owen is the
it's like the war cry of the of the
cavalry so and there's a comes from an
old song and it's it's just a historical
thing and that's why you read the book
you can find out about Gary Owen it's
their marching song
back to the book captain Toni Nadal
Alpha Company was the first man out of
the creek bed leading first Platoon in
the assault he recalls we moved about
fifty yards when we ran into the enemy
force which had come down the mountain I
presume they were preparing to launch
their attack about the time we launched
ours the fighting quickly became very
vicious at close range we took many
casualties lieutenant wayne johnson the
1st platoon leader was hit at least
three other squad leaders were also hit
two of them killed one while going
forward in attempt to rescue one of his
soldiers against direct orders
against direct orders I'm going out to
get my buddy Tony Nidal had ordered his
men to fix bayonets for the attack Bill
Beck firing a burst from his m60 machine
gun to his right front was transfixed by
what he saw just forward a tall thin
sergeant bayonetting of North Vietnamese
in the chest
it was just like practiced against the
straw dummies forward thrust pull out
move on one two three captain Toni Nadal
had four men and his command group as he
charged into the brush
two radio operators sergeant Jack del
and a 25 year-old native New Yorker and
specialist spec Ford John Clarke of
Michigan plus the company's artillery
forwarded observer lieutenant Timothy M
Blake 24 from Charleston West Virginia
and Blake's recon sergeant sergeant
Floyd L read jr. 27 years old of Heth
Arkansas as they moved up Nidal had the
radio handset to his ear a burst of
enemy machine-gun fire swept across the
group sergeant gale was hit and dropped
without a sound Nidal kept moving until
the long black cord pulled back on him
he was looking around to see what was
wrong the same burst that killed
sergeant Gale had also killed lieutenant
Blake and suck instructs sergeant Reed
who died shortly thereafter sergeant Sam
Holman native sergeant Sam Holman jr.
and native offense of a native
Pennsylvanian knelt beside his mortally
wounded buddy Jack Dell and heard him
gasp tell my wife I love her
Toni Nadal had no time to mourn Jack now
Jack L a man he greatly respected too
many other lives were in his hands on
the right flank of the Bravo line
lieutenant deal was now rolling around
on the ground desperately trying to
dodge a valley of machine-gun slugs
cutting through the grass all around him
suddenly 25 yards away Deol saw an
American get up and charged forward
while everyone around him was flat on
his belly
says deal I saw him throw a grenade
behind an anthill and empty his weapon
into it then he fell to his knees I said
to myself please get up don't be hurt I
didn't know who it was I couldn't make
out the form there was so much
battlefield haze dust and smoke it was
lieutenant Joe marm he had spotted an
enemy machine-gun dug into a big termite
hill it was chewing up both Bravo
Company platoons after failing to knock
it out with a law rocket and a grenade
and a thrown grenade he decided to deal
with it directly he charged through the
fire tossed a hand grenade behind the
hill and then cleaned up the survivors
with his m16 rifle
the following day lieutenant al Deveny
found him dead North Vietnamese officer
and 11 enemy soldiers sprawled behind
that termite mound says deal Joe marm
saved my life and the lives of many
others
lieutenant mom staggered back to his
position with a bullet wound to his jaw
and neck he joined a growing stream of
walking wounded flowing back toward the
battalion aid station
sergeant Keaton treated mARMS wound and
one of Bruce Kendall's krandalls Huey's
evacuated him to the rear within days
lieutenant Joe marm was recuperating at
Valley Forge Army Hospital near his home
in Pennsylvania in December of 1966 Joe
marm reported to the Pentagon with a
secretary of the army acting on behalf
of President Lyndon Johnson presented
him with the Medal of Honor the nation's
highest award for valor
dome arms heroic action unfortunately
failed to open the door to the cutoff
platoon Bravo Company had progressed
only about 75 yards Alpha Company a bit
further
all through of Nadal's platoon leaders
were now either dead or wounded as were
many of his non comms
worse yet alpha company's first Platoon
had gotten out ahead of the two other
and was heavily engaged with perhaps a
hundred enemy some of the north some of
the Alpha troopers bypassed the enemy in
dense brush and those North Vietnamese
had opened up on them not only were we
unable to punch through to rescue her ex
platoon we were now in danger of having
another platoon cut off and again I
apologize it's one of the things I
should have talked about was the way
this terrain is set up right so there's
a lot of grass like I would say
waist-high grass maybe a little bit
taller than waist high and it's if you
take cover you can't say anything mm-hmm
because you're in grass yeah if you
stand up you get shot so it's it's a
terrible catch-22 do you stand up so you
can see what's happening and see where
people are going and see where the enemy
is maneuvering and you might get shot or
do you lay down where you take comfort
you have a better chance of not getting
shot but you can't see anything captain
to Dirac ran up to me and shouted
Garryowen sir now this is this is
awesome so captain diderik is the guy
that's coming in - he's from 2:7 he's
coming in as reinforcements and like I
said Gary Owen is like their war cry
yeah so here we go captain - Derek ran
up to me and shout so this is how more
talking he's on this embroided war zone
been taking so many casualties and
here's what Hal Moore says captain -
Derek ran up to me and shouted Gary Owen
sir captain - Derek and Bravo Company
2nd battalion 7th cavalry 120 men strong
reporting for duty his eyes sparkled
with excitement and the challenge of the
situation I told the directors to
assemble his men in a clump of trees 30
yards northwest of the command post to
act as a battalion reserved for the time
being it's awesome
coming reporter Gary Owen Garriott sir
captain Udall says the fight continued
for another 20 or 30 minutes with
neither side making headway it was
getting dark and casualties mounted and
I decided we were not going to be able
to break through I called Colonel Moore
and asked for permission to pull back
and here's what Colonel Moore says with
night approaching there was no real
choice I did not want to get into the
hours of darkness with my battalion
fragmented with the companies incapable
of mutual support and subject to defeat
in detail Ward came over the radio and
this and so now this is a specialist
Galen Buncombe who's out there with the
loss platoon back to the book word came
over the radio that we would have to
hang on till morning I could not believe
what I heard I thought there was no way
we would be able to do that others
thought the same thing
Clarke kept asking me do you think we'll
make it I didn't know but I said we have
to pray and pray hard it was a big
question mark in all of our minds we had
to keep our cool and bear down and now
we hear from Hal Moore again I now
considered the toll this days fighting
had taken Tony into dolls Alpha Company
had lost three officers and 31 enlisted
men enlisted men killed or wounded and
now reported effective strength of two
officers and 84 enlisted John Heron's
Bravo Company had lost one officer and
46 enlisted men killed or wounded and
was down to four officers and 68
enlisted men with one platoon Eric's
trapped outside the perimeter for almost
eight hours I had been involved in the
minute-to-minute direction of the battle
now I wanted to personally walk the
perimeter and check the preparations for
what promised to be a tough night and
another tough day tomorrow
just before dark sergeant major Plumlee
and I broke away from the command post
and set out to check the perimeter
talking with the troopers and getting
for a feel for the situation on the
ground what concerned me the most was
the morale of the men how well the
companies were tied in their defensive
fire plans and the
situation with ammunition and water
supplies morale among the men was high
although there was understandable grief
over the friends we had lost the men and
I talked the men I talked with realized
that we were facing a fierce determined
enemy but he failed to break through our
lines they knew the fight wasn't over
I heard weary soldiers saying things
like we'll get him sir and they won't
get through us sir their fighting spirit
had not dimmed and they made me proud
and humble in every one of my companies
that had landed in this place this
morning there were 15 to 20 soldiers who
had less than two weeks left to go in
the army
some of those men now lay dead wrapped
in Poncho's near my command post the
rest of them were out on that perimeter
standing shoulder to shoulder with their
buddies ready to continue the fight
37 miles to the northeast Bruce Crandall
and Big Ed Freeman finally shut down
their Huey's at alarm at a huge
helicopter pad nicknamed the turkey farm
outside the wire at Camp Holloway they
had been flying non-stop since 6:00 a.m.
it was after 10:00 p.m. when Crandall
shut down and tried to get out of the
aircraft that is when the day's
activities caught up with me my legs
gave out as I stepped on the skid and I
fell to the ground for the next few
minutes I vomited I was very embarrassed
and it took some time to regain my
composure someone slipped me a bottle of
cognac into my hand and I took a big
slug it was a waste of good booze it
came up as fast as it went down I
finally quit shaking and made it to the
operations tend to recap the day and
plan the next the aviation unit had
quite a day we had not suffered a single
fatality and we had not left the mission
undone when our infantry brothers called
we hauled the standard for combat
assaults with helicopters had been sent
on this day I wondered about tomorrow
would it be worse I wasn't sure I could
handle another day like today then again
I thought about the troops in x-ray and
the choice was not mine to make
and here's how more talking about the
wounded back to the book all of the
wounded all of our wounded flown out of
x-ray by krandalls Huey's ended up at
Charlie Company 15th medical battalion
1st Cavalry Division which was
temporarily set up in tents at Camp
Holloway the executive officer of
Charlie med was Captain George H killing
28 from st. Louis Missouri
Charlie meds five surgeons tried to
stabilize the soldiers coming off the
helicopters the treatment we provided
says kenneling was designed to keep the
blood flowing through the patient system
until he could be gotten to a hospital
which had the personnel and equipment to
perform definitive surgery Charlie meds
doctors tied off perforated blood
vessels to stop the hemorrhaging and
then pumped in whole blood telling
recalls that many of the casualties will
rapidly bleeding to death so it was a
race against time to get blood into the
soldier faster than he was losing it
even while the surgeons were trying to
tie off bleeders we threw caution to the
wind and gave a patient four cut downs
which is an intravenous tube tied into
blood vessels with four corpsman
squeezing the blood bags as hard as they
could it was not unusual for the patient
to shiver and quake and lose body
temperature from the rapid transfusion
of so much cold blood but the
alternative was to let him die so
they're giving blood directly into the
veins and they've got corpsman standing
there squeezing the bags of blood to try
and keep people alive back on Elsie
here's Sergeant John shtetl and talking
they probed us all night long we had a
few men wounded I had never been in a
situation like that when they would come
at us they would come screaming and we
could hear bugles
as darkness fell Savage was on the radio
with lieutenant bill riddle herons
artillery forward absorb observer
walking the high-explosive barrage is
all around the cutoff platoon all of us
were lifted off the ground by the impact
and covered with dirt and branches
Buncombe recalls Savage told them on the
radio that was right where we want them
we hollered that it was too close but I
looked back were those first rounds hit
and saw three men running towards us we
opened up they must have been crawling
up on our position when that artillery
came in they would sneak in as close as
ten yards or less and many times just
stand up to laugh at us we would mow
them down it begins to work on your mind
what are they laughing at I couldn't
believe it
the North Vietnamese launched three
separate attacks to keep the pressure on
the trapped second platoon during that
long night each time sending about 50
men against the Americans and each time
being beaten back by artillery and rifle
fire savage had seven men unhurt and 13
wounded nine others were dead some of
the loss platoons wounded continue to
fight including Sergeant Reuben Thompson
who had been shot through the chest a
platoon later heard still another large
enemy force moving down the northern
trail toward x-ray and again brought
artillery fire down on them this was
followed by a flurry of hand grenades
back and forth at about 4:30 a.m. within
an hour the first light in the eastern
sky revealed dozens of khaki clad enemy
dead scattered all around the little
knoll the trap platoon had survived the
longest night any of them would ever
know they checked their ammunition and
prepared to receive a dawn attack and
here's one of the platoon sergeants
talking patoot sergeant Robert Simmons
and Jemison
at first light we sent out on patrol
Staff Sergeant Sidney Cohen spec for
Arthur L Bronson and three other men
were picked to go says Jemison they
saved us from being surprised they
spotted the enemy on their way back into
an attack position they came running
back with Bronson screaming their common
Sarge a lot of them get ready I told
them machine gunners to hold their fire
until they were closed PFC Willie God
bolt 24 of Jacksonville Florida was hit
while firing from his position 20 yards
to sergeant Jameson's right Jemison
remembers gal bolt hollering somebody
help me I yet I'll go get him lieutenant
Joe Haeg
they would go the Joe jiggin George
Aiken PFC Willie F God bolt 24 of
Jacksonville Florida was hit while
firing from his position 20 yards to
Sergeant Jemison's right Jemison
remembers gall bolt was hollering
somebody help me I yelled I'll go get
him
lieutenant George Hagan yelled back no I
will George Aiken moved out of his
position in the foxhole to help God bolt
and was shot this was ten minutes or so
from the time the firing first broke out
struck in the back of the head
lieutenant john lance jack joe jegan was
killed instantly the man he was trying
to save PFC god bolt died of his wounds
shortly afterward the enemy was now
closed to within 75 yards of Edwards
line they were firing furiously some
crouched low and at times crawling on
their hands and knees others no taller
than the elephant grass they were
passing through came on standing up and
shooting they advanced screaming at each
other and Edwards men leaders were
blowing whistles and using hand and arm
signals a few were even carrying 82
millimeter mortar tubes and base plates
this was clearly an no hit-and-run
affair they had come to stay and here's
Joe Stedman talking or sergeant John
Sarge Anse Devlin it was John Steadman
talking it seemed like half a battalion
hit us all at once he hit us headlong
and he hit us strong I thought we were
going to be overrun when Charlie hit us
he had this strange grazing fire he shot
right at ground level trying to cut off
your legs or if you weren't deep enough
in your foxhole he shot your head off
when he started firing at us it came
like torrents of rain you just couldn't
get your head long up long enough to
shoot back you just stuck up your weapon
pulled the trigger and emptied the
magazine
lieutenant Charlie Hastings our forward
air controller had already swung into
action
sensing disaster Hastings made an
immediate instinctive decision I used
the codeword Broken Arrow which meant
the American unit on the in contact was
in danger of being overrun and we
received all available aircraft in South
Vietnam for close air support we had
aircraft stacked at a thousand foot
intervals from 7,000 feet to 35,000 feet
each waiting to receive a target and
deliver their ordnance and here's how
more by now I was convinced that the
enemy was making a primary effort to
overrun us from the south and southeast
and I alerted the reserve platoon for
probable commitment into Charlie or
Delta Company sectors the noise of the
battle was unbelievable never before or
since and two wars have I heard anything
equal to it and here's specialist Arthur
Vieira the gunfire was very loud we were
getting overrun on the right side
lieutenant Kroger came out into the open
in all this I thought that was pretty
good he yelled at me I got up to hear
him he hollered at me to help cover the
left sector I ran over to him and by the
time I got there he was dead
he had lasted a half an hour I knelt
beside him took off his dad dog tags and
put them in my shirt pocket I went back
to firing my m79 and got shot right in
the elbow my m79 went flying and I was
knocked over and fell backward over the
lieutenant Vieira now grabbed his 45
pistol and began firing it left-handed
and he says then I got hit in the neck
and the bullet went right through I
couldn't talk or make a sound I got up
and tried to take charge and was shot
off with a third round that one blew up
my right leg and put me down
it went in my leg above the ankle
traveled up came back out then went into
my groin and ended up in my back close
to my spine just then two stick grenades
blew up right over me and tore up both
of my legs I reached down with my left
hand and touched a grenade fragments on
my left leg
and it felt like I touched a red-hot
poker my hands just sizzled unbelievable
attack and I think that script
description right there really spells
out how intense this was and when
obviously we got chrome more saying that
this is the loudest thing he's ever
heard in two wars that also confirms
what we're dealing with here back to the
book at 7:45 a.m. the enemies struck at
the left flank of toning dolls alpha
company at the critical elbow where
alpha and Charlie companies were tied in
we will now under attack from three
directions grazing fire from rifles and
machine guns shredded the elephant grass
and swept over the battalion command
post an aid station leaves bark and
small branches branches fluttered down
on us several troopers were wounded in
the same command post and at least one
was killed my radio operator spec for
Robert Peel let 23 years old had a
perspective of a speckled 6-4 from
Madawaska Maine was hit and slumped over
in a sprawl unmoving and seemingly dead
I kept the handset to my ear and here's
Joe Galloway the reporter the incoming
fire was only a couple of feet off the
ground and I was down as flat as I could
get when I felt the toe of a combat boot
in my ribs I turned my head sideways and
looked up there standing tall was
sergeant major basil Plumlee Plumlee
lean down and shouted over the noise the
guns
you can't take no pictures laying down
there on the ground sunny he was calm
fearless and grinning I thought he's
right we're all going to die anyways so
I might as well take mine standing up I
got up and began taking a few
photographs
Plumlee moved over to the aid station
pulled out his 45 chambered around and
informed dr. Carrera and his medics
gentlemen prepare to defend yourselves
so clone we thought they were getting
overrun - or at least gonna get close
you're in the aid station that's in the
center of this whole perimeter and he's
pulling out his 45 and saying prepare to
defend yourselves you can't make that up
specialist Willard F Parrish 24 years
old and a native of Bristow Oklahoma was
an assistant squad leader of one of
Charlie company's 81-millimeter mortar
squads Parris was one of the mortar men
who had been outfitted with the spare
machine guns and rifles collected from
our casualties input on the Delta
Company perimeter Parrish recalls when
we were hit I remember all the tracer
rounds and I wondered how even an ant
could get through that back to a right
we started hearing the guys hollering
they're coming around they're coming
around I was in a foxhole with a guy
from Chicago Jay PFC James II Coleman
and he had an m16 I had my 45 in his 45
and I had an m60 machine gun we were set
up facing out into the tall grass I was
looking out front and I could see some
of the grass going down like someone was
crawling in it I hollered who's out
there nobody answered and I hollered
again no answer I turned to I turned to
Coleman burn his ass Coleman said my
rifles jammed I looked at him and him at
me then I looked to the front and they
were growing out of the weeds I just
remember getting that machine gun from
there on out and the training takes over
and you put your mind somewhere else
because I really don't remember what
specifically I did I was totally unaware
of the time the conditions on that m60
machine gun according to the extracts
from his Silver Star citation specialist
Paris parish delivered a lethal fire on
wave after wave of the enemy until he
ran out of ammunition then standing up
under fire with a 45 pistol in each hand
Parrish fired clip after clip into the
enemy who were 20 yards out and he
stopped their attack says Parrish I feel
like I didn't do any more than anybody
else did up there I remember a lot of
noise a lot of yelling and then all at
once it was quiet the silence out in
front of Willard Parrish was that of
this Cemetery
more than a hundred dead North
Vietnamese were later found where they
had fallen in a semicircle around his
foxhole 45 in each hand that's that's
crazy actually
I mean you yeah he's he's going to a
whole nother level yeah because you
can't reload you know you can't reload
your pistol so maybe he maybe he would
stand up fire both just dump a mag and
each around and each pistol
get back down reload them both but then
he get up that's after he used all of
his 60 ammo George Fox 25 and Nathaniel
Byrd 22 were slumped across their silent
m60 machine gun surrounded by heaps of
empty shell casings and empty ammunition
cans they had died together shoulder to
shoulder
sergeant Jemison pays them the ultimate
compliment of a professional soldier
bird and Fox did a great job they kept
firing that gun and didn't leave it they
stayed on it to the end
so all this closed air sports coming in
this whole time artillery is coming in
the whole time and all of a sudden they
get a situation where they start they
see aircraft coming overhead with jets
coming overhead low-pass and they're
heading towards them and they drop some
napalm so here's how more I yelled to
top my lungs to Charlie Hastings the Air
Force fact call that son of a [__] off
call him off Joe Galloway heard Hastings
screaming in the radio pull up pull up
Matt Dillon says I can still see the
canisters tumbling toward us I remember
thinking turn your eyes away so you
won't be blinded I put my face into a
reporters shoulder to hide my eyes that
was Joe Galloway's I could hear good
time Charlie Hastings shouting into his
radio pull up the second jet did the
napalm from the first hit some people
and caught some ammo on fire sergeant
major Plumlee jumped out to put the fire
put out the fire around the ammunition I
ran out into the LZ to put an air panel
out
sergeant Nye says two of my people PFC
Jimmy Dean Akiyama and specialist five
James Clark were on the other side of me
several yards away somebody was
hollering and Colonel Moore was standing
up there hollering about something about
a wing man and I looked up there were
two planes coming and one of them on
already dropped his napalm and
everything seemed to go in slow motion
everything was on fire
Nakayama was all black and Clark was
burned and bleeding and here's Joe
Galloway before I had walked over and
talked to the engineer guys in their
little foxholes now those same men were
dancing in the fire their hair burned
off in an instant their clothes were
incinerated one was a mass of blisters
the other not quite so bad but he had
breathed two fire into his lungs when
the flames died down we all ran out into
the burning grass somebody yelled at me
to grab the feet of one of the charged
soldiers when I got him
the boots crumbled and the flesh came
off and I could feel bare bones of his
ankles and the palms of my hands we
carried him to the aid station I can
still hear their screams respect for
Thomas Eber Lyle a medical man from
Bravo Company 2nd battalion rushed out
into the clearing with his kit bag to
help of napalm victims burlile was shot
in the head and died within minutes in
lieutenant Rescorla arms an Oklahoma man
burl islet turned 23 years old just four
days before he was killed back in the
command post Part II Air Force FAC
Charlie Hastings was stunned by all the
consequences of the misplaced airstrike
castings recalls after the napalm strike
Colonel Moore looked at me and said
something that I never forgot don't
worry about that one Charlie just keep
them coming
yeah I mean he knows what he's got to do
he's got hass things that just killed
some of his own men wounded some of his
own men by fire and he's freaking out
probably don't want to call any more
bombs on and how more realizes that's
what's keeping him alive yeah don't
worry about that one just keep him
coming Charlie Company 1st battalion 7th
Cavalry had begun its day with five
officers and a hundred and six men by
noon it had no officers left and only 49
men unhurt a total of 42 officers and
men had been killed and 20 more wounded
in two and a half hours of vicious
hand-to-hand fighting the bodies of
hundreds of slain Vietnamese North
Vietnamese littered the bloody
battleground
spec for Pat's Selleck 24 in the native
of Mount Kisco New York says I remember
one guy had a small American flag on the
back of his pack when I saw that I felt
very proud it's something that always
stuck with me this American flag was put
on top of a blown-up tree just like AO
Jima another battle we had won for the
United States that little flag flew over
landing zone X ray for the rest of the
fight raising all our spirits and now
there's a lull in the fighting and here
we go back to the book during this lull
the saddest most painful and hardest
duty to endure was collecting our dead
and loading them onboard the helicopters
there were so many that the brigade
ordered the big choppers the ch-47
Chinook s-- on such helicopter lifted
out all 42 of the dead from Charlie
Company they came in together died
together and now left together
wrapped in their green rubber Poncho's
spec for Vincent Cantu says we were
picking up our dead and placing them in
the choppers some of these guys I had
known for two years yet I could
recognize them only by their name tags
their faces were blown off it was hard
not to get sick we would look at each
other and without saying a word
just continue putting our dead on the
choppers
now the colonel that's in charge of the
both both battalions he makes a visit
and here we go mid morning before Tully
arrived Colonel Tim Brown flew in for a
visit home Lee recalls Lieutenant
Colonel Moore saluted Brown and said I
told you not to come in here it's not
safe
Brown picked up his right collar lapel
and waggled his full Colonels eagle at
Moore and said sorry about that Dillon
and I gave him a situation report
Brown asked whether he should stay in
x-ray established a small brigade
command post and run the show we
recommended against that I knew the area
and Bob Tully and I got along just fine
Brown Aggie agreed
lieutenant dick merchant says Colonel
Brown had trust and confidence in his
commanders I'm aware that some felt he
should have landed an x-ray and
established a command post I've never
accepted that the 1st battalion 7th
Cavalry was probably the finest
battalion in Vietnam well-trained
superbly led with outstanding officers
and NCOs throughout the unit Brown would
have been out of place in x-ray besides
there was no room for brigade CP I
recall it being rather crowded behind
that anthill so the reason I put that in
nurse because here's the the guy that's
you know Hal Moore's boss comes in to
check on the scene and some people say
oh he should have stayed there because
it's a bad fight and he in this dick
merchant said no like he shouldn't
stayed there he did the right thing he
came visited and left and by the way you
want to set up a brigade command post
you need to find your own little ant
hill because this one's oh this one is
you know the size of yeah it's full and
it's the size of a car we got dead and
wounded everywhere and so but it's it's
the important point there from my
perspective is you know the key thing is
that he had trust and confidence in his
officers he didn't need to go out there
and micromanage them and I'm not saying
you could never do that
I'm definitely not saying that's the
dichotomy leadership you know
sometimes you might look out there and
say there's something going on I need to
get out there need to get in the weeds
and get this problem handled I need to
come out there and support in this
particular case probably wouldn't have
been a good idea how Moore had it under
control at this point that's why they're
landing a Chinook which the ch-47 giant
helicopter much bigger than a Huey you
know it's a slower and at least on
approach it's slower so yeah there's a
time to get out there and micromanage
and there's a time when you let your
team's lead okay going back to the book
in Myron diderik and Lieutenant Rick
Ross Scola so these are the two guys
that came from the second battalion 7th
calves and he just talks about him a
little bit I think it's worth mentioning
Rick Rescorla and Myron diederich Bravo
Company 2nd battalion had two
foreign-born officers whose accents and
gung-ho attitudes lent a touch of
Foreign Legion Flair the Ukrainian two
Durack and the Englishman Rescorla was
were destined over the next 72 hours to
become battlefield legends in the
seventh cave as much for their style as
their fearless leadership under fire and
yeah it's it's it's you can see what
these leaders do and you do get to see
it but here's when when to dirac
remember he touched down and he was told
hey go go set up security and here we go
Myron did Derek and his soldiers had not
yet been sorely tested but they soon
would be during that wall - Derek made
certain that fields of fire and
observation were cleared out - beyond
200 yards that good fighting positions
were dug that machine guns were placed
in positions that assured that assured
flanking interlocking fire that trip
flares and anti-intrusion devices were
installed as far as 300 yards out that
every man was locked down loaded down
with ammunition and that a me ammo
resupply points were designated that all
radios were checked and double-checked
then diderik worked very carefully with
his artillery forward observer
registering pre-planned fires across the
front the officer the officer Lieutenant
William lund had four batteries 24
howitzers registered and adjusted
on-call so that's you ever wonder what
uh when a military leader does that's
what he does right there dials
everything in
and here he's talking about us so one of
the durricks platoon leaders was Rick
Rescorla and here's what he says about
Rick Ross Carla
Ricker scroll of 1st platoon leader was
six months out of OCS at the infantry
school at Fort Benning but he had
arrived there with a wealth of good
training already and in under his belt
he had served in the British Army in
Cyprus and with the colonial police in
Rhodesia and he knew what soldiering was
all about what he did to prepare his
position and his men speaks for his
professionalism so here's what Rescorla
did restaura walked the terrain and
tried to see it from the enemy's point
of view that's critical what's the enemy
thinking scrub brush elephant grant
grass ant hills and some ground cover
stretched to the front the ground was
not as flat as it first appeared but had
seams and thick ruts stretching off to
the south with a slight incline away
from his positions the hasty prone
shelters dug by Charlie Company 1st
battalion had been dug after nightfall
under enemy pressure Rescorla moved his
men back 50 yards which not only
shortened the sector but meant the enemy
would now have to leave the trees across
40 yards of mostly open area to reach
Bravo Company foxholes Rescorla recalls
because of our shortened lines I
decreased the number of foxholes three
manholes were constructed the m60
machine guns were set on principle
directions of fire from which they could
switch to final protective grazing fire
interlocking with each other and with
the machine guns on our flanks foxholes
and parapets were built in details I
tested the holes some were so deep the
occupants could not even see the pair
over the parapet in these cases firing
steps were built back up two hours
before dusk
sergeant each balk a27 and Sergeant
Thompson organized a booby trap detail
carefully they rigged grenades and trip
flares far out on the main avenues of
approach claymore mines claymore mines
would have iced the cake but somewhere
they had been lost a screw-up but I felt
we were ready to tangle with the best of
the North Vietnamese and again these
guys are luckily there's a lull and they
have all the time to prepare this and
get it all set up and that's a big
difference from what happened when these
guys hit the LZ and they didn't have any
of this stuff they didn't have any of
the terrain figuring out they'd have it
chance to sending their personnel up and
these guys are taking advantage of that
tactical situation to get up there and
make things right and you know both
those guys you can see that's what a
leader does mmm that's what a leader
does they make sure things are right
they make sure you're ready to win and
you can do that and that applies to
every every leader in every position in
every industry and every team in the
world though the leader is stepping up
and making sure we are going to be
prepared to win and by the way this Rick
Rescorla and this is a little bit of a
side note he ended up working for Morgan
Stanley as the head of security for
Morgan Stanley and they worked at the
Twin Towers in New York City that's what
Morgan Stanley was and he felt like they
needed to do drills like they needed to
prepare and that what happened if the
towers came under attack and they ran a
bunch of drills and when September 11th
came they ran those drills and got
everyone evacuated and Rick Rescorla was
last seen on the 10th floor going back
up into the building to do a final check
and make sure that everyone was out and
the tower collapsed at 9:59 a.m. then he
saved a lot of lives that day not only
through his actions on the day of but
through his actions in preparing now the
Vietnamese come the North Vietnamese
come and they bring it here we go the
first rush by at least 300 North
Vietnamese was beaten off in less than
10 minutes by small arms machine-gun and
artillery fire from the alert and
well-prepared Bravo Company 2nd
battalion troops at 4:31 a.m. 20 minutes
later they came back to dirac said the
intensity of their attack increased and
I was under the under assault aimed at
my three left platoon sectors screams
shouts and whistles split the night as
NVA swept down the mountain straight
into the smoke clouded killing ground
now all the mortars of
my battalion and Tully's were turned
loose adding their 81 millimeter
high-explosive shells to the general
mayhem rifleman John Martin who is in DD
wrecks lines says we kept pouring rifle
and machine gun fire and artillery on
them and they broke and ran I don't
think we had any casualties but they
were catching hell so so now it's a
totally different story
these guys are dug in they have all
their artillery dialed in they've got
their fields of fire set up and the
attacks come well-organized act with 300
people there did you can't they think
they don't make it happen mmm the
Vietnamese don't make it happen yeah
back to the book over on the perimeter
scoreless men fought on our m79 switched
to direct fire fire delivered to a
visible target and lobbed rounds out
between 75 and 100 yards still the
shadowy clumps moved closer RPGs and
machine guns crackled as they blasted us
from the dark line of ground cover
across open fields they came in a ragged
line the first groups cut down after a
few yards a few surge right on sliding
down behind their dead comrades for
cover an amazing highly disciplined
enemy a trooper cursed and pleaded in a
high-pitched voice goddammit stop the
bastards so here they are they're
attacking and when the North Vietnamese
soldiers get hit they're their buddies
are coming up behind them taking cover
behind their bodies and continuing to
assault so this is an indicator you know
like I said this was early in the war
this is 1965 and you know we didn't know
that's determined enemy yet we didn't
understand that yet and here we're
seeing it for the first time this is
what this is what this is how determined
these guys are they are going to attack
they're gonna attack through whatever we
put out
here's another situation shtetl in this
is a shtetl and whispered orders to his
squad telling men on either side of him
to hold their fire not to shoot until
the enemy stepped out into that open
space right in front suddenly a flare
and a booby trap went off and they were
there in the grass shooting at us
I took around just above the elbow
nothing really just a stitch or two and
a piece of tape after the flight nobody
shot back then they stepped into that
open area the flares were burning they
were lit up and it was easy
we opened up and picked him off it was a
light attack they then they hit us
harder 30 minutes later blowing bugles
blowing whistles we killed them all then
some white phosphorus came in about 15
front him in front of my hole and I lost
most of my Webb gear and my shirt had
about eight burns on one arm John
Steadman sat there under the light of
the flares and used the point of his
bayonet to quickly dig the still burning
Willie Pete fragments out of his flesh
so white phosphorus is a type of
ammunition that we use and it's it's
white phosphorus and it hits and blows
up it's on fire there's a little pieces
of burning hot metal and he's picking it
out of his arm during the two and a half
hours of the attack against a dirac
sector the rest of the x-ray pruner had
been quiet too quiet Dillon and I
discussed the possibility of conducting
a reconnaissance by fire to check for a
presence of the enemy elsewhere on the
line we had plenty of ammunition and
what the hell the enemy knew where our
lines were by now as well as I did
we passed the word on the battalion net
at precisely 655 a.m. every man on the
perimeter would fire his individual
weapon and all machine guns for a full
two minutes on full automatic the word
was to shoot up trees anthills bushes
and high grass forward of the fort of
and above the American positions Gunners
would shoot anything that worried them
by now we had learned to our sorrow that
the enemy used the night to put snipers
and trees ready to do damage at first
light now is the time to clean up out
front at the stated time our perimeter
erupted in an ear-splitting uproar
and immediately a force of 30 to 50
North Vietnamese roads from a cover 150
yards forward of Jonas Suk Dinis Alpha
Company 2nd battalion lines and began
shooting back the mad minute of firing
triggered their attack prematurely
artillery fire was instantly brought in
on them and the attack was beaten off
when the shooting stopped one dead
sniper dangled by his rope from a tree
in fort of two Derrick's leftmost
position another dropped dead out of a
tree almost immediately forward of John
heroes John herons Bravo Company 1st
battalion command post a third
Vietnamese sniper was killed in the hour
later when he tried to climb down for
from history and run for it
sergeant shtetl ins armed speckled with
white phosphorus burns began hurting him
now I was sent back to the aid station
where my arm was bandaged and I was
waiting to be medevacked out the more i
sat there the more I realized I couldn't
in good faith get on a chopper and fly
out there and leave those guys behind so
I took the sling off my arm and went
back out somebody asked where are you
going I said back to my foxhole nobody
said anything else so obviously these
guys now have gained some some good fire
superiority the upper hand in the battle
back to the book Rescorla and his men
had been watching the airshow
appreciative Lee we gathered for the
last sweep suddenly a fighter bomber
plowed down on us from above we buried
our noses in the holes an express train
screamed down and the explosions shook
the earth the bomb landed 30 yards from
our holes
we came up cursing in the dust and
debris the call came to move out every
available trooper including Colonel
Moore pushed the perimeter out this time
it was no contest at all
we killed 27 more enemy and crushed all
resistance I looked over the field
littered with enemy dead sprawled by
ones and twos and heaps across a torn
gouged land
blood body fragments torn uniforms
shattered weapons littered the landscape
it was a sobering sight those men our
enemies had mothers too but we had done
what we had to do aside from wanting to
make certain that de Dirac and his men
did a clean safe job I had one reason
for joining the final assault personally
this is this is Colonel Moore talking
and then it goes to Rick Ross Carla
Ricker scola watched Colonel Moore in
our sector was rushing up the clumps of
bodies pulling them apart what the
hell's the colonel doing up there
sergeant Thompson asked I shift my head
later we saw him coming back at the head
of men carrying Poncho's by 10:30 a.m.
Colonel Moore had found what he was
looking for three dead American troops
were no longer missing in action now
they were on their way home to their
loved ones by now late morning Tuesday
November 16th the personality of landing
zone x-ray had changed what previously
had been a killing field had become
something else
we moved without impunity in places
where movement had meant death only
hours before except for our own
artillery and air there was nothing to
be heard
it was just too quiet too sudden and it
made me uneasy that old principle
nothing was wrong except that nothing
was wrong
where was the enemy headed back to
Cambodia still on the mountain preparing
to attack again headed north to the IED
ring and it's precious water and again
the old question where would the enemy
12.7 millimeter heavy anti-aircraft
machineguns
if the enemy commander brought those
weapons to bear on us from the mountain
above LZ x-ray with three American
battalions crowding the clearing would
present a beautiful target I told Dillon
to step up the harassing artillery fire
and to keep the airstrikes coming in the
slopes above us I told him I wanted a
picture-perfect helicopter extraction
covered by all the firepower we could
bring to bear
so yeah tides have turned completely and
in fact they've turned so completely
that a Chinook which is the big
helicopter flies in with a bunch of
photographers and television crews and
reporters and they surround they
surround Colonel Moore and here we go
back to the book the other reporters now
clustered around me I told them that
this had been a bitterly contested
battle that clearly we were up against a
brave determined and very tough enemy in
the North Vietnamese soldiers but that
American firepower discipline guts and
will to win had carried the day at LZ
x-ray brave American soldiers and the
m16 rifle want a victory here I said my
voice choked in my eyes filled with
tears as I told the reporters that many
of my men who had been killed in this
place were only a matter of days away
from completing their service in the
army but they fought and died bravely as
I stood there I knew that the telegrams
that would shatter the hearts and lives
of scores of American families were
already being drafted now came the body
count and if you remember we talked
about this before everyone was always
they wanted to talk about the body count
in Vietnam even at this early stage and
he was thinking about that back to the
book now came the body count from the
beginning of the fight I had known that
higher headquarters would eventually
want to know what damage we had done to
the enemy so after each major action in
this battle hating it I asked my company
commanders for their best estimates of
enemy killed with the battle raging back
and forth over three days and two nights
it was anything but orderly there was no
referee to call time out for a body
count we did the best we could to keep a
realistic count of the enemy dead in the
end it added up to eight hundred and
thirty-four dead by body count with an
additional 1215 estimated killed and
wounded by artillery air attacks and
aerial rocket attacks on my own I cut
the 834 figure back to 630 for a
personal allowance for the confusion in
fog of war and let the hundred
1215 estimated stand we captured and
evacuated six enemy prisoners on our
side we had lost 79 Americans killed in
action 121 wounded and none missing and
at this point they get extracted off the
battlefield including Colonel Moore he's
the last man to leave from his battalion
and here we go back to the book it was a
short fast ride to landing zone Falcon
just a five and a half miles east of
x-ray as we landed among the artillery
pieces I saw 75 yards away a group of my
troopers off in the northwestern edge of
the LZ Dean Bareilles an NBC News
correspondent was in LZ Falcon that
afternoon he captured the scene in his
1967 book the face of South Vietnam and
here's what Dean Bareilles wrote how
Moore was the last man to come out of
the battle it was the biggest battle he
had ever fought he was a lieutenant
colonel and he carried himself like a
proud man his sergeant major was at his
side it would need a Shakespeare to
describe to what happened then but it
was something that was love and
manliness and pride it was the moment of
the brave how Moore turned and went from
group to group of his men and only a few
bothered to get up because there was no
exclusivity now no rank and how Moore
did not want them to stand and salute he
was saluting them he talked with them he
thanked them he was not solemn and he
did not bring to his greetings the
salutations of a bullet above a
politician
there was no poverty of spirit in his
hand shook shake and he shook every
man's hand it was a union of men
who had met and defeated the enemy not
forever not in a victory that ended the
war but in a victory over their
uncertainty when their hour had come
they had done their job and it was this
thought to that Almore how more had in
his mind and he said that if they had
won no one else's gratitude they had his
and I think that these men all these men
have our absolute gratitude for fighting
for freedom for fighting for each other
for fighting for us and and actually the
story doesn't end there
nor does the book and we're gonna save
it for the next podcast but we're gonna
hear about the story of LZ Albany which
is a few miles to the north in still
inside the I drank Valley where 2nd
battalion of the 7th calves moved in and
fought and it's there's so much that I
didn't cover in this in this what I
discovered there's so much I didn't
cover me didn't even cover the loss
platoon who does eventually get
recovered read the book I should have
left that out spoiler alert
but there's so much in there there's so
much so many lessons learned so much
action so much good description and so
many heroes in so much sacrifice I don't
even think gratitude I mean the
gratitude is enough I think we owe them
more than just gratitude we owe them our
best we owe them our lives our best
lives every day every moment to remember
this sacrifice and what we owe them as
we owe them to live our best lives and I
think that's all I've got for tonight
so echo yeah well I did compress over
here maybe you can give some input on
how to support this podcast or support
yourself if you want to sure yeah if you
want to so of course the first way is
supporting your joints I always talk
about supplements chocolate supplements
best kind
chocolate joint warfare and supercro
krill oil Omega threes very good for you
if you want some of that get it at
origin mein kampf right there in the
front or you just click on labs it's
right there also there's some good G's
but before that give a new product we do
a new product out yeah yeah a new class
of product class of product ivory
workout now you're on a pond right now
yeah buzzing on it right now yeah so
discipline it's a pre-workout it's a
call saying that's a co-worker that's
the name both both so it's called
discipline all right so it's free if
technically they call it a pre-workout
but we're calling it a pre mission yeah
supplement well pre-workout would help
you with your physical activity sure but
the discipline has cognitive enhancers
in it as well yeah because when you're
on a mission you just don't need
physical strength you need mental
strength
yeah so this gives you both yeah so if
your mission is the workout boom there
you go it's a pre-workout your mission
is a exam mm-hmm it's a pre exam yes
supplement if your if your mission is a
mission well you're good to go
pre mission there you go boom oh yeah
get down um I too can vouch for this cuz
I'm on it two should perform well - you
know display its effects also G's and
rash guards at origin me all made in
America the more I think about that the
more of a big deal that is it's a real
big deal yeah cuz it's from a little
like oh we say the cotton to the the
ghee or the you know the other stuff
that there's a lot of cool stuff on
there jeez rash guards even a pair of
all made in America or gin me.com this
is about to get them if you want I want
them I like them it's funny like every
once in a while often find myself just
wearing all origin stuff not on purpose
- it's the kind of my favorite shorts
even though they don't have them
I know wearing that it wear every other
day approximately and you know you just
find yourself in the stuff it's so good
that's my opinion
also for fitness gear cool fitness gear
you want to even if you're just doing
kettlebells I say get the artistic
kettlebells from on it on it calm /
chuckle that's where you get them
there's all other creative workout stuff
on there maces and cool jump ropes and
battle ropes and whatnot pretty much
anything if you're getting bored with
the workout and you want to enhance it
in some creative way go there on it calm
/ chuckle don't get addicted to the
website cuz a lot of good information so
it's kind of a catch-22 good you can get
info on there a lot of good info
interesting info but you might spend a
lot of time there so be careful also
when you buy this book We Were Soldiers
Once and young by General Howe Moore and
joe galloway you know I was thinking
I have no idea what you're thinking so
something tells me I'm about to hear
though if you watch the movie a few good
men mmm
I think it did me more yes she plays uh
like she plays a Jag lieutenant yes I
seen the movie her name the character
name is Joanne Galloway but call her
Jill so her name is Jill Galloway I
noticed that anyway when you buy this
book we were so years later there's
there's some layers that David those are
interpreted layers or not layers laws or
coincidences there's a big difference
it's a fine line Charlie Beckwith that
formed up Delta Force
sure being in this book that's layers
that's layers yeah yeah I I would
confirm those layers for fair layers for
sure I don't know I I still feel like
Joe Gallo is layered somewhere I don't
know what if they negative no of this
these stories and they name the good
they could negative maybe maybe not and
if they did they failed they failed yeah
cuz just the wrong carry on after it
yeah so really we convene oh the way I
still think it's layers either way when
you um when you buy this is the one you
buy this book we have it listed on our
website along with all the books that
chocolate reviews it's on the website
choco podcast.com in the section open
top menu click books from podcast boom
it's all there by episode click through
there good way to support get from
Amazon you know all that stuff and then
you know continue do do more shopping if
you want if you want just carry on there
you go good way to support also
subscribe to the podcast iTunes Google
Play stitcher Spotify confirmed someone
sent me the actual link vision I saw it
visually visual confirmation Spotify
boom and other podcasting providing
platforms just subscribe I know you have
already but let's say in the odd
likely unlikely a chance that you didn't
subscribe good subscribe good way to
support if you want also subscribe to
youtube if you liked the vision the
visual the video version of this podcast
you'll see what Jacque looks like you
don't see what I look like if you care
about that sort of thing
boom most people don't care what we look
like no I I don't I don't think it makes
sense that they don't get good doesn't
matter they just care about the content
of your character subscribe to YouTube
that's the point if you do care about
what we look like also those excerpts on
there good way to get little bits of
lessons messages from Jocko shareable so
you don't have to share the whole two
and a half-ish our podcasts you can just
share the excerpts pass them on you know
let someone else learn these lessons
with you also chuck was the store it's
called Yakko store named after him John
goes door comm that is where you can get
the cool shirts I think they're cool and
I think it goes beyond just my opinion
because people have emailed me and been
like hey these are cool because I made
sure they're not the low quality you
know people when they start a shirt
brand or if they're printing shirt
they're like hey let me get the cheap
one so I have to spend a lot of money
play it safe all this stuff I didn't do
that I got the good ones stuff that I
would actually wear regardless of what's
printed I like it wearable they're
wearable that's how I put it anyway
that's why I know they're good I'm
wearing one right now yeah correct
me too boom see I wouldn't wear it if I
didn't want to wear it so anyway they're
very good that's what you can get the
shirts there's women's stuff on there
also this rash guards on there for
activities such as surfing jiu-jitsu
warrior kid rash guard out there yeah or
eq'd rash guard should be reached on
there should be on there good I've vowed
to get them in in time to ship for
Christmas so that would be like today
so go on there and you know that's the
the my vow
is that the right word Wow why would I
do this that means you better succeed
yeah you know this so here yeah yeah
some rash guards on there for jujitsu
surfing you know kind of cool activity
cycling whatever anything you want range
of motion to be maintained 100% and
performance be increased by 19% I think
it's up to 21%
back from the field yeah yeah I think I
kind of average cuz some people a little
bit more you know so those people they
push the average up I think that's how
it works
anyway cool stuff on there check it out
nothing get something but if you want
something then you get something and and
it supports podcast good way to support
hoodies on there as well thicker ones
they might be writing along I might have
to get some more it is winter I get it
but they're there the thick ones like
how you said also psychological warfare
what that is if you don't know I know we
all know what it is already
it's been number one and I - well might
not be number one anymore that's a long
story
anyway if you don't know what it is the
unlikely event that you don't know what
it is is what it is it's an album with
tracks chocolate tracks each track is
designed to help you through moments of
weakness when you're on your path when
you're on your warpath
I mean you so did mmm wait maybe I have
I don't know nonetheless when you're on
the path of discipline right you're on
the program you're on your campaign
against weakness you you hit little it's
not just one smooth road and it's not a
one straight road either and it's
riddled riddled every day probably every
minute literally riddled with
distractions every once in a while
you'll hit moments of weakness whether
it's a speed bump distraction lack of
energy
boredom repetitiveness tediousness
tediousness that's a word
that's what psychological warfare is for
it's a little spot for those moments you
don't want to wake up early every single
day ah
we got the solution for that listen to
the little track jockle pragmatically
telling you I can get over that little
moment of weakness
same thing with wanting to skip the
workout for the day that was mine
that was mine anymore Jack and yeah
there's a bunch of them for all kinds of
stuff keeping on the diet it's a good
one
that's what psychological warfare is
very effective
100% effectiveness that's a bold
statement and you can get jock a white
tea on Amazon which will make you
deadlift
eight thousand pounds it's actually
confirm confirmed you can get some books
on their way the warrior kid good
Christmas gift it's also good whatever
gift so get I'll kid on the path get
them on the path got so much great
feedback on that extreme ownership this
is for leading at every level in combat
in business and in life extreme
ownership written meet by me and my
brother life Babbitt also from an
individual perspective if you want to
get yourself on the path there's no
better gift than discipline the
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
everyone that asked me for workouts
that's where they are everyone asked me
what I eat that's where it is everyone
asked me how much I sleep that's where
it is so get that if you want the audio
version the audio version is not
inaudible the audio version of
discipline equals freedom Field Manual
is on iTunes Amazon music Google Play
and all those other mp3 distributing
platforms there's another muster the
muster which is echelon front Leadership
Conference there's two of them gonna be
only two of them in 2018 hmm we don't
have enough of room in the schedule to
fit three one Washington DC or sorry
this is actually not one it's number
five so number five Washington DC May
17th and 18th and then number six San
Francisco October 17th and 18th come and
get it you can register for those
extreme ownership calm is are they gonna
be like bigger you know like you'll have
to make sure they can have more people
we have a we have a little bit bigger
capacity yeah yeah but we just we don't
have time in the schedule anymore
and we are gonna do the roll call for
law enforcement military firefighters
we're gonna do that as well but we
haven't blocked a date on that one yet
also for leadership in addition to this
podcasts in addition to the books in
addition to the muster we have a
leadership and management consulting
company and you can hire us to me Lafe
Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke email
info additional on national and front
comm if you want us to come and speak at
an event don't call a speaker's bureau
don't call a speaker's agency just go to
Ashe just go to Ashland front comm you
know they've been calling me yeah don't
do that that's what we do and if you
have comments or questions or answers or
for us we can be found on the interwebs
on Twitter on Instagram and on the face
pokeball echo is at Echo Charles and I'm
at Jocko willing and thanks to those
people those soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines that sign up that sign up and
volunteer to make the ultimate sacrifice
thank you all for protecting us and our
freedoms and to police and law
enforcement thanks for protecting us
from crime and criminals and terrorists
right here at home to paramedics thanks
for coming to us in our time of need
when we call and to the firefighters
right now out there on the line
especially in our state right here of
California Cal Fire thanks for your
service and your sacrifice and my
condolences to those who have fallen in
recent days and weeks and our faults are
with the families of the Fallen and for
everyone else that's listening when you
see what men can do when pushed beyond
the limit of human capacity when you see
that when you hear about it when you
read about it well then remember
to push yourself push yourself every day
every moment get out there and get after
it and so until next time this is echo
and Jocko